Are we all captivity in Ontario.
That's beautiful.
We live [inaudible].
I just got a tweet from filled the,
that dude is on the the trainer Wallace training.
They banned a killer whale captivity in Ontario.
Rich Vos doesn't give a fuck about that though.
Do you read your blogs at all?
One of my biggest missions in life is the killer where they kill the kill.
I just too much feedback.
I'm trying to get this feedback like it's,
there's like a humming Jimi Hendrix,
Wah Wah Wah Wah.
Is there a hum like it?
How do I turn it down?
It's a,
there's an obs,
right?
Is there a house?
Not a hummer.
I lie because I fucked up so I wanted to make it look like there was a reason I
fucked up.
Where do you turn it down and whatnot?
This right here.
Oh boy.
You guys that talk to [inaudible] testing one,
two there.
Oh my God.
That's too loud.
Yeah.
It's a little weird.
No in between that.
Okay.
It's like a fucking good right there.
Now it's sucked.
I'm like a Prima Donna when it comes to salmon.
I to tell you the truth.
I hate wearing headphones.
Don't do you.
You don't have to wear them.
I don't know.
Take them off.
I liked,
I liked their little ones.
Uh,
perfect.
It is sounds like a whole new Mac and cheese.
I just do this.
We'll let Jamie,
we handle everything.
I have.
Shit gets weird.
Let us know.
No,
I,
you're going to go crazy and stick with the headphones.
Like the headphones.
He's gangster.
Look at him over there.
He periscoping this live your life.
Did you go back to the little phone?
Oh,
that's the snow I'm using the Samsung Edge.
very nice.
Nice.
And actually works very well.
I'm very happy with it.
It's great
deaf phone.
It's a very sweet phone.
Yeah.
I got it for the Ting.
I got a um,
um,
a GSM card.
Yeah,
that's what I did.
Unlocked phone and uh,
it,
it's cool.
That camera's so amazing compared to it.
Uh,
and if you compare that like the iPhone six with it,
it's like night and day difference.
How much better they though the local mall.
Yeah,
the cameras.
Yeah.
I'm a big fan of that Samsung phone.
They make us flip phone,
that new one,
the new galaxy,
the s six and the s six edge or there's so the quality is so much better than
the five,
but I really wish they didn't have to go with the um,
the,
now it's not waterproof anymore and you don't have replaceable media storage.
She can't,
you know what's really good battery out,
you know it's really good though is this one I was completely dead and it has
such a fast charge on it in my car in like 30 minutes,
it charged up to 56% of the battery and like 30 minutes.
It was almost completely,
it's great.
I liked them,
I liked them.
Or you anti-technology ritual.
I got this,
the iPhone six plus cause I wanted to make my little hand even look smaller when
I hold it.
I can't tell you how many times I lay in bed trying to play scrabble and it
falls out of my fucking around and it's just the most aggravating thing on the
planet.
But I'm,
you know,
I,
what do I use it for?
I take some pictures and uh,
maybe I'll record something.
Internet,
uh,
Twitter and you went on was do I need a fucking phone for,
you know,
I mean,
what,
what recording.
That's it.
You know your videos I take of my kids and that's it.
You know,
so the cameras and these new phones are fucking incredible.
The people that make cameras mostly so bummed out because they used to think
those little point and click cameras that everybody used to have that market
buys those nights.
I started a lady the other day,
took a pitch.
Not only that,
how about the people that buy do ones that are disposable?
How white trash are you that you don't,
that you're buying a disposable fucking camera,
bring it somewhere and get it to develop.
Yeah.
You got to stick this,
these pictures are great.
Cause then I'll send this to my iPad,
to my,
uh,
to my Mac book and I'll send them all,
you know,
it's fucking,
I don't even send them,
I put it right next to it and it,
it downloads to,
to,
to my iPad.
Did you ever see that Robin Williams movie?
24 hour photo.
It's one of my favorite movies.
It's great movie.
Yeah.
Amazing.
But today you'd be like,
why would you go quit?
Doesn't make any sense.
Why would you like to get developed?
And you have a printer equity.
I have films that long.
Do you have any film that you haven't developed?
Like I just found a camera that when I was 20 I met a girl on AOL or she lived
in Chicago.
My Mom's like,
I'm going to Chicago.
And it was 20 years ago.
It was like the first girl I ever met on AOL.
It was [inaudible] 95 something.
It will one or two and I met her own thing and we used to go back and forth and
my mom's like,
I'm going to Chicago for work.
And I'm like,
hey,
that girl lives in Chicago.
So I met her and we spent a day together in Chicago.
Don't remember what she looked like,
but the text you sent me,
someones trolling you obviously.
Oh yeah.
I found out.
Of course he thought it was funny to say that he was so solid.
Well,
you'd have to be,
you would have to been like 16,
17,
17.
But I was looking at,
and there was one girl that I had sex with,
I don't remember who she was and they couldn't be there.
Uh,
just tell him,
send me the pictures of me.
Well,
he said it was Asian.
I was like,
Oh,
I had my first Asian a couple of years ago.
The worst is when you macro,
like,
I met this girl once and she was hot and I flew to Florida a couple of days to
have sex,
you know,
and then like all of a sudden she,
I'm going out to lunch with her and our mother,
like,
what the fuck?
She's probably,
she's a stripper.
She's pure dysfunction.
And we go to hotel.
All of a sudden I fucking right when I bust a fucking nut,
all I think is how am I going to get out of this whole situation?
I mean,
I'm talking another day and a half of this fucking horribleness and he was hot,
but it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
It matters enough to get you into the mess.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Well it's like,
it's like anything,
like when you're comping and fucking free base or crack,
the whole excitement is going up there and getting through to guns and you know,
dealing with,
you know,
and not fucking,
you know what I mean?
And then you get,
it's like you get to home and boom.
Now I got it.
I made it through,
you know,
the minefields.
I got to fucking crack.
I smoked it all right.
But the whole excitement leading up to it,
you know,
uh,
the best thing that ever happened to me with these fucking broads,
when I'd pick him up and take him back to my place,
uh,
and my shitty apartment,
I,
they,
they can never stay.
I said,
listen,
you got to leave because my ex wife drops my kids off in the morning and I can't
have my kids see and you know,
you okay and you're stretched out of one of my ex wife seen you knowing that I
went from her to you.
You know what I'm saying?
So Larry is getting them out is,
you know,
when you talk about traveling and getting lazy,
it's amazing the difference.
And I don't even know if women,
I don't think they have this experience,
the difference in perspective of before you have sex with them and then after
you have sex with him,
it's so radically different.
Like before you have sex with them,
you can't wait.
You like looking at her ass and look at her waist and her tits.
You like,
oh this is going to be a man.
And then when he'd done it like,
Oh God,
what am I doing?
That's the difference between being with a girl you really do care about and
being with a girl that your body just tricked you.
You know?
And that can happen to a guy and that's why,
you know,
like if you have sex with a girl and then afterwards you're hanging out and
talking and cuddling and you love it,
you're like,
oh,
she's really nice.
I really like her.
I didn't get tricked this time.
It's like you don't even know until the fog clears.
I go,
Oh,
where are we?
hello.
Hi.
It's so weird how instant it is.
Immediately showed disgust on you could be with a girl and,
and everything's great like say,
and then all of a sudden the way,
uh,
she throws a piece of garbage in the wastebasket and your room,
you go,
I hate her.
Just one little Taylor.
I wish with this girl,
I'm telling you,
I get,
it was right after my first divorce.
I was working South Carolina and I met this girl.
You couldn't have been any better looking smart,
a great career newscaster show in South Carolina.
We're fooling around.
It was great.
I'm like,
did I really find love again?
Right.
You know what I mean?
I was like,
ah,
she's beautiful.
Fun to be with.
Uh,
he came to Alabama where I was working,
I guess,
whatever.
It wasn't far and we great weekend denim in Florida and she flies down to see me
and,
and we're laying in bed and I'm really sick.
I have a fever.
And she goes to touching me,
go to what can I do?
And I go,
well,
the first thing is get your fucking arm off me.
I like the AG said,
but don't talk to me.
And then I knew,
I knew like you have to get outta here and I can't,
I can't hand,
I cannot,
I can't do this.
And it was perfect because I'm so fucking damage in life that I'm going to
destroy everything around.
You know what I mean?
When you have that damage personality and that,
you know,
the whole I'm not good enough,
I'm not where you somehow you're going to fuck it up.
You know?
That's what's great about Bonnie.
She's his damage as I am.
It's like,
you know,
she really,
really
loved me.
Tell you something.
Let me tell you a story.
Okay.
And we told on our rage,
she grew up on a fucking farm.
Okay.
When she,
I guess 11 or 10 she had to have a major operation,
you know,
something removed from down down here.
I don't know what it was.
It was God,
I wish,
I wish you still had one of them.
So she had to have it removed.
Right.
11 years old and she lived in Cold Lake and her parents put her on a bus to go
have the operation and like Toronto or wherever,
10 or 11 years old,
maybe nine by herself because her parents couldn't leave because it was harvest
season and there were farmers,
they put a nine or 10 year old girl on the bus to go have him go have part of
her body taken out.
Oh my God,
in the hospital,
you know,
and then come home.
You know what I mean?
I think maybe they visited her at one point,
but she grew up poor and the beginning sleeping on dirt floors,
you know,
and then,
uh,
you know,
farmers and killing chickens and this and that and you know,
but she was always creative.
Brilliant.
Fucking,
I read one of her books,
she made us a kid called a chicken island.
You know,
she wrote a book as a kid,
just brilliant,
brilliant.
And that's how my kid is.
And,
and,
and then if you don't think she's damaged,
she went out with Mark Cohen,
who's a guitar act.
How can you not fucking nothing against a guy.
Good songs.
Uh,
he's a comic and a female,
whatever.
That Guy,
Huh?
I don't know.
He was married,
had kids and his wife
did some cancer stuff or whatever.
And I always got along with him.
He was a good guy.
He was a nice guy.
He was a great guy.
Everybody liked him.
He was funny.
I don't think so.
He's probably just doing whatever,
you know,
just never hear his name anymore.
And sometimes that happens,
you know,
you look around the guy all the time and then for whatever reason you don't hear
that name anymore.
They just stop exchanging circles or circles.
Stop interacting with each other.
There was this guy,
Anthony,
I knew when you would always hear his name,
Anthony Cooma and whom you whom you know and you don't hear his name anymore.
He's still preaching to the converted.
He said,
how many,
do you know how many podcast subscribers he has?
Cause he's subscription only.
Yeah.
Which I
think I'm 22,
22 people now he's doing,
I think he's doing our right.
I think he's done all right.
He charges like five bucks a month or something and they have no,
I think he's doing,
I've done this pocket.
It was a lot of fun when I went out again,
if he was in New York and they are sending up in New York,
then it'd be like he needs to move to add based though.
If he moves to add based,
he'll be fucking huge.
He's really good.
He's funny.
He's a funny fucking guy.
Not only show,
he's very smart,
he's politically smart,
knows politics.
He knows what's going on,
but people are not going to pay.
They're not paying to subscribe to things,
especially when you can for the same amount.
You can get all the channels on Sirius,
all of them.
How many do shows do you do a week?
You do like three a week for do you do for a week?
April.
Which $5 a month?
I mean really if you think about enemy,
it's not that much,
but it's actually broke and you have to make,
make your decisions.
You know,
there's a lot of people that are broke.
Like that's a lot of people don't like serious for that very reason because they
have to,
they have to think,
okay,
that's another five bucks and then this is another five bucks and that's,
it all adds up if you're,
if you're chipping away,
that all adds up.
I see so much free content nowadays.
Even with periscope,
I was just watching Burt Christ or the other day for like an hour and you know,
that's all free and that was just like a podcast,
but it was live.
And Joey does mean around the morning joint.
Joey Diaz,
every morning gets up at seven o'clock he lets everybody know,
like gives you a 10 minute warning on Twitter and at seven o'clock you'd like to
join.
It's just talking shit.
And he talks shed for like five minutes.
And then he says,
all right,
go wash your pussy.
I have a good day.
You motherfuckers gonna kill it,
kill it out there.
And he gives you like a little motivational
beach.
But I,
I think that that kind of shit is the future,
you know?
And he's going to get ads for periscope.
That's what he's going to do.
That's how he's going to handle it.
Yeah.
That's the future.
I mean,
look,
Anthony,
I hope you don't all set financially.
I don't know how long it's going to last.
I don't know how,
you know they did pretty well.
You know his house.
Have you been to his house?
No,
I've seen pictures of it.
It looks like Victoria.
God,
he used to live there.
It's fucking beautiful.
You know,
it's real,
you know,
fucking statues pouring,
whatever,
you know,
it's kind of fucking money.
I'm serious.
Serious game.
A ton of money.
Yeah.
You know,
he was done with them forever.
Those guys,
they were with any wn serious,
you know.
So did series want to get rid of them cause they were paying so much money.
I doubt I take now.
Now.
Yeah,
because our corporate and once you say you would take it was all of her money.
Oh I think that there's a lot of money problems over at that place.
They're trying to get you the article about them cutting Howard Stern's money.
I think they're cutting the fat is pretty much what they're probably thinking
about right now.
But they just took a huge loan out.
Uh,
yeah.
Like was it a year ago?
Millions and millions of dollars and this was like the second huge learn I think
that they did just to kind of bailed him out and give him some time.
But I told your stock went up.
I thought they were down to like get to $1 and 30 cents 10 cents.
Oh yeah.
So I mean you could,
it became rich real high at one point in time.
Was that force $4 a doll?
You know,
I don't understand stocks.
It was realized,
but I just know if this makes no sense that a company could be worth four times
as much with the products.
Exactly the same.
Like,
oh,
what,
what's going?
What's happening?
They can crash,
the stock can crash.
But what,
what changed?
I think the idea of stocks is fucking completely ridiculous.
Do you buy stock at all,
Joe?
Oh,
you said invest in Twitter right now though,
with this periscope buffalo the fuck off.
When you make any money at all?
Man,
I have people that do it.
Yeah.
I mean I do have stocks.
I have,
um,
I have funds,
I invested a bunch of different things,
but quite honestly,
I just,
I think the days of people making fuck tons of money just on,
on stocks there,
those days are numbered it.
So it's weird times now.
I don't really know what I'm talking about.
I shouldn't say that.
I've,
I fucking knew almost nothing about finances.
I invested in,
this was years ago,
I think maybe $2,000 back when it,
and,
and my problem is I have a gambling problem like every other problem.
So every day I'm looking at it to see if it went up or down,
you know,
and,
and it's,
you know,
it was going to go on,
this is doing great.
Then all of a sudden dropped.
And I just said,
fuck it.
I gotta stop just because all I'm doing is thinking about is just,
and it's only like fucking 2000 bucks or 3000.
But what you invest in,
it was a mutual fund.
So it was a bunch of things together,
right.
And I ended up saying,
I'm done with this.
I made like 400 bucks,
but I would have lost it all.
I would have lot.
And it wasn't much,
but it's just,
it consumes your head,
you know?
Cause if you're,
if you're game,
if you're in Vegas gambling,
you're thinking,
oh fuck,
I lost it here.
If I get it back here,
if I do this,
if I,
you know,
if I just get 300 today and 300,
you know what I mean?
I identify,
get even then may back in fucking when a little here and that's all your head's
going on when you're gambling in Vegas,
you know,
numbers and numbers are going through your fucking head.
Nonstop and Vegas.
All right.
Any casino,
and I can't even imagine which stocks,
how thing.
Yeah,
it's the same exact thing.
Yeah.
You're sitting there all day.
You got 10.
Say you got 10,
you got 10.
Uh,
you're invested in 10 different companies all day long.
You're back and forth.
This fucking company,
Susan,
this is,
I get to throw money over here from here.
You know the fuck it's too much.
Just go shoot craps and either winter fucking lose.
Yeah.
It certainly is gambling and in that a lot of guys that are attracted to
gambling,
they get involved in stocks.
Then they get the same itch,
the same itch.
It's going up and fucking salad.
Look at the floor when you see the floor and they're yelling and screaming at
each other,
which I don't even think they do anymore.
I don't think they do it the same way.
I mean I think what we were talking about,
um,
that with people that understand who the fuck was it we were talking with when
they was talking about how they've,
um,
that people have bought property closer to Wall Street so they could trade
quicker cause it trading with algorithms and it's all about like now seconds.
Like literally that the distance in the pipe between the,
the office and the,
the floor,
the trading floor is,
makes the difference between selling and buying at the right time.
How it's like a lot ping.
Yeah,
exactly.
So they invested in all this real estate around that area.
Real estate around Wall Street is fucking worth astronomical amounts of money.
Well,
there's just all you need is a small office.
Take that some off and you put all your servers and all your stuff and they do
all your,
all your um,
transactions from there.
And it's amazing.
Well,
a lot of the stuff I learned about Wall Street and stock was from trading places
show I'm pretty,
I know a lot about it.
Does it go,
she reference point?
They know that was good movement.
Uh,
I see these guys,
but you know,
during the whole market crash and the banking and I,
and I'm not really the smartest when it comes to the sub Keck.
Uh,
when people lost their homes,
the fucking life earnings,
not one of those cock suckers,
you went to jail.
Okay.
But you fucking,
you know,
do whatever,
uh,
you know,
who,
mock.
They're stored in jail for a couple,
but no one from Wall Street,
whichever indicted for anything other than that Bernie Madoff guy.
But that guy was just stealing.
It was a totally different,
and it wasn't Wall Street.
That was to divert your attention from Wall Street.
That was just a Ponzi scheme.
Well,
no,
he had nothing to do with Wall Street.
That was a Ponzi scheme.
Right.
Okay.
He wasn't working down on Wall Street.
He was just scamming people for money.
That,
that wasn't the banking,
you know,
uh,
giving mortgages to people that can't afford them and you know,
it started off with the real estate is start off with a real estate salesman.
Yes,
we can get you into this house then to the broker and to the bank and they're
giving out these fucking houses to people that get Bernie and dad kept people's
minds awful.
Really what was going on down in Wall Street because it happened at the same
time.
What amazed me about that Bernie Madoff things that people that understood money
got robbed.
Like a lot of people,
they,
I guess it was just great,
I guess like he was offering such a large percentage of return on your money
that people just,
they just said,
look,
I'm going to take a chance.
This fucking guy,
whatever he's doing,
it's doing it right.
People make it 25% returns on it's crazy returns,
but it was just,
he just banked on people not cashing in,
which is just amazing.
But when's enough enough to when like how much money,
like there's people that lost millions,
you know,
so when's enough,
enough for a person or if you know what I mean,
like look,
take cooperation.
It's when's enough,
enough where you're going to start treating your fucking employees,
like human beings start giving all operations a very tricky because with
corporations it's all about they have to continue to make more money than they
made the last year.
It's all about infinite growth.
So like if you made $1 million this year,
you have to show them,
you know,
in a first quarter of the next year we're up 5% and you have to keep doing that.
If you don't keep doing that,
then you're losing money because you have stockholders and your main obligation
is to earn the stockholders money.
Yeah.
That's what you have to do.
And if you don't do that,
they'll get rid of you as a CEO.
Well,
she,
same as any comedy club.
I go to a comedy club,
if they make money and I make money,
what?
Happy.
As long as you don't lose,
you know,
I fight with comedy clubs.
I go,
well,
you didn't lose last time I was there while we didn't make,
look,
you didn't lose it was a,
there was a prophet.
Okay.
Uh,
I talked to these employees from Costco after a show a couple of weeks ago.
They're fucking paid 30 something.
And our health insurance,
uh,
you know,
kickbacks from whatever they spend there.
I mean,
this corporation is great to their employee cost.
Yeah,
they're fucking great.
I'm telling these ladies that had been there 20 years,
18 years,
that are making 35 bucks an hour and,
and,
and getting health benefits and,
and whenever they byproducts,
their percentage of that goes into their,
whatever,
fun.
So,
I mean,
it's a great corporation,
but there's other ones,
I don't want to say names because I don't want to get fucking sued,
but you know,
uh,
you know,
when's enough enough,
how much the money,
there's a certain family need before they start taking care of their fucking
employees.
For a lot of folks,
I think what happens is that's the only way that they keep score things,
you know,
the only way he keeps score as money and if you're not making more money than
you were making before,
you feel like you're losing it.
They never feel like they're accomplishing anything less than making money.
They don't have a quantifiable score on anything else.
It's not like,
you know,
like if you were doing something else that you really enjoy doing on top of
making that money,
you know,
like something competitive maybe.
I think there's a lot of,
a lot of what,
what goes on in business has competition.
You know?
I mean it's,
a lot of it is sort of what made human beings human beings in the first place.
It's like this desire to constantly move ahead constantly.
You know,
make everything better.
Progress.
Keep pushing forward.
Like that whole desire that led to cities,
agriculture,
that's the same sort of instinct that leads people to continually pursue and you
get greedy and greedy here.
Yeah,
it's drive.
Yeah.
The best point is when they don't have anything else to fall back on.
You know,
when they,
I don't know.
I mean,
look,
you look at Trump,
I don't know about his,
I know he knows how to build a fucking golf courses.
This fucking guy who knows how you're a golfer,
so you understand that.
I've been to some of his courses.
He got confused.
Yeah,
he golfs.
You know,
I've heard stories,
but he golfs.
Heard stories,
but it was socks.
No hoodies.
Okay.
I heard his.
I,
I'm,
what stories have you heard me say?
He plays a lot of golf.
He plays a lot of Campbell.
Oh,
I don't think so.
I don't know.
I never,
No.
Just saying he'll fly
in on his helicopter,
you know,
but he likes to when he's,
he likes to win in life and maybe like say let's even say we'll use a Malcolm x
term by any means necessary.
He likes to win.
Okay.
So I don't know.
I feel racial tension in the room.
No,
no,
no.
Uh,
awkward boner,
but okay.
So he's is,
is well off in life,
but at least on the side he's doing something that gives him passion.
Do you know any,
he's building these golf courses and he's going a plan.
I'm not pro Donald Trump or anti or saying,
I'm just saying that this is a guy that besides building big fucking skyscrapers
all over New York and everywhere he's got his,
his thing is building and playing golf.
Remember what he was going to say.
A little bottle wasn't born in America who was like,
he was chasing that down.
Obama was born in Kenya and his birth certificate was fake.
But you know,
she'd be funny when that all comes out in Obama says,
you know what you got?
He's done.
Look,
interest of total disclosure.
I am in fact the radical Muslim terrorist of infiltrating and trying to weaken
America from the inside of you.
White people in Iowa.
We're all right.
Yeah.
The one people on the hill,
all those fucking crazy Christians at that take back America folks.
Have you heard the Rick Santorum Song Take Back America?
We played it yesterday.
Who's ever an office there?
Every the other side's going to hate him and trash him and do whatever.
I mean,
look at Butch stunk.
Obama is not the best president on the planet either.
None of them.
None of you know,
if you're a fucking Jew that votes for Obama.
There's gotta be,
I mean,
he's not really,
really pro Israel.
You know,
he's not an [inaudible],
but he's not so do you have to be pro Israel is a big cause.
Here's the thing,
you don't have to be pro Israel,
but antisemitism that runs rapid throughout Europe.
Rampant it.
That's the word.
It's rapid as well.
No,
I'm fucking,
this isn't a fucking the Bonnie or Norton correcting me.
I say something wrong words.
I mean now and then,
but you know what I'm saying.
But you know what I'm talking about?
What did I say?
Rapid.
I'm pretty sure he'd say rapid.
No,
Brad pit or rapid,
I bet you can say ramp.
It runs rampant or rapid.
Rampant or rice and ramp it.
Let's look it up.
Rampant.
I said rampant.
It's rampant.
Rampant.
Okay.
What'd I say?
Ramp.
You said rapid?
I'm pretty sure it runs rat.
Could have been anything.
It could have been,
but you know what I was talking about how basically,
okay,
antisocial it.
Just in case someone listening is young and impressionable and they might go use
that same word like when they were running,
you're going for a job interview or something like,
okay.
Well,
you know,
I think disinformation runs rapid throughout this world.
Okay.
I,
we'll talk about a couple of things.
I know that I can't fuck up.
Okay.
Uh,
so Jews,
Obama what?
Okay,
so the antisemitism throughout Europe,
right?
How to control,
oh,
have you seen that thing in France?
You know,
they,
they had,
uh,
this,
guy dressed up as a Jew walking through these,
uh,
Muslim neighborhoods in Paris.
Like,
Whoa,
there's some fucking sear.
That's obviously we're Charlie Hebdo happened where they killed those guys for
drawing those cartoons at Mohammed.
Um,
there's a lot of antisemitism in Europe.
Yes.
I was talking to Ari about it and uh,
Ari and his brother,
his brother actually lives in Europe and he said that essentially they were just
like really tolerant of,
uh,
of all sorts of different religions and a lot of like really radical people
moved there because of that,
because it was a good place for them.
Well,
it's going to overflow.
Whatever happened,
it overflows to antisemitism in his cabinet.
People in this country really think huge run this country.
They really think that,
huh?
Do you really can hear I'm getting these newsletters and three,
I,
I was explaining to a comic,
you know,
you run this kind of,
there's 3% of us in this country,
3% now.
They've done really well though.
Yeah,
she was good.
Yeah.
But how could you,
if we did that would say the other 90% 97% are pretty fucking,
we need to get this number 3% now.
Now wait a second.
Now we just had,
and I'm saying this just Kinda,
you know,
you know the wash run this country,
fucking Walmart,
Chase Manhattan Bank.
It's all fucking waspy old school money,
right?
But dish fucking world and country could not survive without cues.
Medicine,
science,
the arts.
Fucking we have given back more to this country.
You were player that,
yes I am.
I kill on stage every time I listen to me.
If you're in Ventura this weekend at the Ventura harbor common again on there
Friday,
it's a great place.
Friday through Sunday,
I,
they have top notch comedians there.
I'm there this week or this week,
I don't fail.
Okay.
A word or two might get messed up,
but you'll know what I'm saying.
But I'm not going to fucking fail.
So Jews have given back to society.
We've won more Nobel prizes,
percentage for science and medicine than anybody else.
That's true.
Jews.
They're like number one when it comes to biology.
Fuck these phones right here.
What do you think that technology came from?
LSD.
Koreans,
glues.
No,
no.
There are Chinese people and Steve Jobs,
he did ask these Wazniak they listened to.
He was the genius behind it all.
I,
no,
he dared the ones who build the technology in them.
Oh,
Jews.
Yeah,
sure.
Yes.
Part of the phone right here.
Okay.
Three fists to this phone.
She,
that's the part with the notifications here.
This area Asian.
Okay.
Asian.
Is that this area right
here,
down in the bottom corner.
You Know Italians?
Yeah.
My people don't contribute shit.
Yes you do.
I would never buy a Ferrari.
Ever the fucking tires or fly off on a highway.
You guys pay attention construction.
What?
Are you kidding me?
You're running construction?
Maybe barely little artistic stuff,
but not,
not nothing engineering wise.
I don't trust them.
Hey.
Nah,
you know Italians,
I got to admit Dave.
Dave had a lot.
I'm not impressed how you're not not impressing my own people.
I don't know.
I just fucking kill you.
Didn't she?
Boardwalk Empire.
I fucking,
I saw him.
He held up in,
you know,
it's just,
I think that like when it comes to technology,
the people that are most impressed with the Japanese and the Germans,
Japanese and the Germans seem to,
especially when it comes to engineering like a cars,
automotive engineering,
it was hard to fuck with those two people.
Yes,
I have a Japanese and Germans like fits it.
You know,
Americans are like a third now.
Americans like the new American cars are pretty fucking good.
Like have you seen those new Cadillacs look like space ships,
cts vs the fucking beautiful man.
I mean they finally nailed it.
Like the new,
I drove one of those escalades I rented an escalated,
it's amazing.
The new one is fucking fantastic.
It is a great car.
It handles like a,
like a much smaller car.
I mean it's an enormous SUV but they have this magnetic control suspension and
it handles like,
like a,
like an s class Mercedes.
It's incredible.
The entire dashboard is a screen like the dashboard.
Is it like a laptop?
Like there's no real gages like it.
It's a,
it's a laptop screens and LCD screen.
Also bad ideas.
You know what else is great?
The navigation system is fucking huge.
So you get this huge screen that's your,
all your gauges,
you gauge cluster,
it's all lcds.
And then to the right,
that navigation screens fucking massive.
I'm going to start off at the expensive and if it's really sunlight daylight,
it is that can you not see or you're like damn,
it has a light sensor in it.
So it turns dark.
It turns black when it's a at nighttime and it turns white way to daytime.
I just show that's what it looks like.
I just fucking see that LCD cluster there.
That is all one big screen.
Like all that shit you see where it's two gauges,
it's not really two gauges.
That's all.
That's all one flat screen.
And so is the a thing to the right,
the navigation scream.
I was very impressed.
That's someone's tits.
I would,
uh,
I don't know.
It was probably someone calling you or something.
I would totally buy one of those.
I,
you know,
I have the Lexus,
that big Lexus Suv,
which I love,
but I would definitely buy one of his Cadillac,
you know,
so funny of tech.
Not like I have two German cars,
but I don't have navigation in them.
What?
Well,
I,
I have a 2013 Mercedes,
no navigation,
but I have,
you know what's funny,
I have a Garmin or whatever,
but you could tell she had an old,
and this is in a bit,
this is true,
but it will be a bit as of this weekend,
uh,
when I,
when,
when she talks to me,
she's breaking up.
It's like she's getting old
and dying.
The voice in my Garmin,
like she'll go make a turn at exit and then it will stop and she'll stop talking
and then it will pick up again and,
and I feel like the whole thing is just,
she's dying,
whoever the lady is.
You know what I'm saying?
It's so outdated that the fucking,
you could feel you I have to put it to rest and get a car with navigation or
what the problem as all of them can't fuck with this.
Yeah.
This is the best.
When I Google something,
I want to know what it is and then it says directions and I pressed directions
and it goes Bluetooth through my,
uh,
through my stereo.
Oh ways man.
With the police,
like you know when the police are up ahead,
you know the police are using ways and they're,
they're faking police stops there.
The calling and fake ones to ways just to fuck with the whole system.
Well my bond use,
I haven't used this yet.
It eats up a lot of data,
doesn't it?
When you a dress.
So I don't know.
I don't know.
It doesn't go well.
What are you worried about your dad and cutting on your prices down to Ventura?
Well,
let me explain something to you.
Okay.
I have three fucking kids that are,
two of them are elks or on my phone.
Okay.
Two,
two older daughters that I have to cut.
Luke 24 and 22 there's still on your plan?
Yes,
I,
yes,
I know.
Cut To,
Cut Him loose a fucking job kid.
No.
My daughter,
22 years old,
just moved to Houston,
called me last week 22.
Uh,
I just got hired starting at 50,000 a year.
That's pretty fucking good for a 22 words in it.
And you send in what you do for a living hot.
Uh,
she's a buyer for her.
She's a buyer for like clothing.
Oh,
okay.
Cool.
And my other daughter graduated for 22.
That's a great gig.
That's fucking a real great gig.
That's very good.
That's what must be talented.
I'll put her on my family plan.
Give her,
give me her number.
Yeah.
I really,
I'd rather give it,
I'd rather give her number to Farah Khan and give it to them.
Okay.
If you're concerned about data,
as an example,
I just switched over to t mobile,
$50 or $100 a month.
You could have up to five phones and unlimited everything.
Data,
everything.
You could have up to five phones on it.
That's pretty amazing.
I'm what t mobile.
It's got the best network.
At least in Los Angeles.
It's the best.
Better.
I'm on a better than Verizon as far as phone calls I've had,
I've had both Verizon at and t and sprint compared to t mobile and the last like
six months.
And Verizon actually was the worst where I lived in Los Angeles and then B where
you live and that's important.
You know where you got to find out where you live.
Like I used to live in a spot where I could only use a t and t like at and t was
the only thing that worked.
Comedy House comedy store,
uh,
Verizon who is almost zero bars but uh,
are not t-mobile.
It's like 30 upload.
Well that doesn't make any sense cause I use the Verizon at the comedy store all
the time and it works perfect.
Yeah,
I'll do a speed test with you tonight or tomorrow.
It wouldn't download,
test,
download and upload.
It's amazing.
Maybe that,
but as,
as like phone calls,
which was all I use it for other than like occasionally I do periscope from
there,
which I like doing now.
That's fine.
Yeah.
But this phone I bought this,
uh,
you just falling six.
I bought it through Verizon phone and they'll buy it from you.
They'll,
they'll pay your,
your contract charge that you'll pay me off.
Cause once you're,
you know,
I mean I'm fucking locked in with Verizon.
I mean it's just some gangster shit pay.
They'll pay all of the contracts and that is to get you out of it.
They're losing money like crazy,
but they're just that this new president,
that t mobile has a,
he's an amazing guy and he,
dude,
I've made fun of t mobile my whole entire life.
It was the best which I've ever made.
And now you're saying it's unlimited data,
unlimited everything.
How long before they have it where it's like in China,
in China you can be in the middle of the forest and you get five bars.
They said that it's unbelievable.
Like they have the best cell phone signals that is,
I don't know what they have.
Five G is about to come out.
Is it really?
Yeah.
When is that coming on?
Next three years.
I think.
This is what they're saying.
What is that going to be like?
[inaudible] fast [inaudible] movies.
Yeah.
Hd Four K you guys,
you're taking off.
You Go,
Oh,
I need this movie.
And before it hits the air.
Yep.
You have to move.
It's awesome.
I love dish phone when it comes to the phone.
I love it.
It's a great phones at the top end phones now,
like the Samsung,
the galaxy s six and the iPhone 60 they're amazing.
It's just hard to complain.
Fucking skyping with my kids and it's amazing.
It's just amazing.
This stuff.
What does that 10 gigabytes per second?
So 10 kids.
Oh my God.
Fast enough to deliver a full length HD movie on your phone in a matter of
seconds.
10 times faster than Google fiber and 40 times faster than four g.
That is fucking incredible.
10 times faster than Google fiber is mindblowing.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what?
We're probably going to wind up doing the podcast through that.
Once it's up,
we'll probably wind up doing that.
And when you start using that,
thank the Jews,
the Jews,
I guarantee it was like a Korean dude who created that.
Let's find out.
Jamie,
get on it.
Nokia.
Korea.
No,
that's like Sweden,
isn't it?
Okeydokey is European.
My peach juice it ringtone.
So the Jews,
the Jews of its Nokia,
I think Nokia is a European company.
Oh Man.
What is Nokia find out?
I'm pretty sure what is Nokia bought it,
but no kia sounds Japanese.
It's a Finnish Finnish,
uh,
sounds Japanese though,
right?
Nokia.
Nokia,
yeah.
Finish whenever finished from Finland.
No,
Jews in Finland.
They have,
they run from hiking.
Fucking watch.
Uh,
the Americans,
the Russians,
bosses like didn't you see trading places?
Like she watched the Americans.
Okay.
You'll learn,
I'm
telling you here is from the TV box.
That's how it works to fucking rapid ascension to grace or whatever it is.
I,
here's somebody Lippitt discrimination.
Here's,
ah,
here's what Joe Rogan started and he didn't even know he started this.
Uh,
we're,
we're doing our podcast,
Bonnie and I,
and I know if we got a tweet or a message at Rogen and theirs and we look up,
we respect you.
We like it.
We think you're great.
And you know,
we're big fans.
And we were,
no,
no.
The blood is what you did.
Uh,
and,
and there's no reason for us to even worry about their spot.
When we heard Rogan,
uh,
in a tweet saying,
Tom and,
uh,
Christine are the funniest comedy couple on the planet.
And Bonnie and I were a little hurt.
So we had to do some research and,
and,
and that's okay because they could be,
I don't know them from Adam.
I don't,
I've never met him.
I hear a thing.
I hear his name and her name.
I never heard him.
I never heard their podcast.
But Bonnie and I,
we put it out there.
If you listen to our podcasts are so long thing,
you know,
uh,
Tom and,
Christine,
uh,
cease and desist,
you know,
stop.
Uh,
we were the first,
but then we looked into what date they did their podcasts before ours,
but we've challenged any comedy couple to tennis,
you know,
that's not comedy though.
I didn't say they were the best tennis comedy cup.
Well,
I mean,
I don't believe in Cambodia,
no oil wrestle,
match tennis,
you know,
and,
and we said,
you know,
we'll play them in monopoly,
you know.
Oh yeah,
I don't even know them,
but I'm going to tell you right now,
they don't want to get involved in a roast battle.
Would ritual walks and Bonnie and macfarlane.
I just what I'm saying cause we'll have to do it in our house.
You,
you are a very funny comic.
And uh,
so it was Bonnie and so are they.
I haven't seen bind you stand up in a long time,
but Bonnie is fucking hilarious.
She's a very funny comic.
And your movie that you did,
we should plug that movie because it's fucking awesome.
Women aren't funny.
It's great.
It's fucking great.
It's really great.
And you can get on iTunes.
It's out there right now and you should get it to support it because Bonnie
edited that whole fucking thing herself.
Director.
She directed it,
edit it.
She's a monster.
I mean she,
she knocked it out of the park.
Um,
but I'm just,
I'm around Tom and Christina on a regular basis.
If I was around you guys,
I'd probably maybe say the same thing about you guys,
but I'm around them all the time.
I'm telling you,
Christina Palicki murdered at the comedy store last week.
So hard.
It was like,
it was painful to watch.
Not Loud.
It wasn't last week because last lawsuit goes in Vegas.
So it was,
it had to be the weekend before she fucking destroyed,
I mean,
leveled
the place.
Uh,
and I,
and,
and she said afterwards,
she goes,
I'm finally starting to like get this room.
She had a late spot and you know,
it's a long shot.
She actually went on after me.
I brought her up.
She fucking murder dude.
She's really good.
I'm not,
I'm not saying stand up.
I've never seen,
I've heard nothing.
I've said,
I'm not what you're saying,
but I'm talking podcast.
Has He ever made her cry and walk off the podcast?
No.
They have a really good relationship.
It's very different than yours.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Has she,
has she ever blown him on their podcasts?
Probably.
I don't know.
Maybe as dirt has not.
He blown you while you guys were doing a podcast,
which we'll do anything for hit.
Yes.
That's what we're about.
Which did you get harder?
Only like three quarters.
You know what's the worst when you're fucking jerking off and you're not really
hard and you come and you're going,
how the fuck did I come and I'm not even hard.
It's getting old.
I fucking,
he's also just disinterested cause I did it once when I was 23 my Bonnie says,
but he say when I was 2015 fucking funny.
Bonnie says every year she gives me one extra second.
This is so funny to,
I could do anything with a girl for sure.
I'm up to nine seconds.
We've been married,
we've been married nine years,
right?
So I have nine seconds.
Well I can do anything I want.
Whether girl for nine seconds.
So you're fucking girlfriend.
Nine seconds for 29 20 year anniversary.
Yeah,
it'll fly 20 seconds.
The other day,
the other day she blew me and I came so quick and she started,
she said,
I'm starting to rethink that whole nine second
isn't it funny girl just puts your Dick in her mouth.
That's not as bad as if you come.
You know,
like if you come then it's like a finalize the agreement.
You've signed the mortgage papers,
it's great.
So it's a human car wash for your Dick.
Not only say feel good,
you're getting your dip cleaned,
she's blowing you with her fucking mouth.
That's one way to look at it.
But what I was saying,
it wasn't weird that it's,
it's she's,
she's concerned not just that a girl's blowing you cause the girl is still
blowing over here the nine seconds,
but that you came like that's the issue that you come.
If you didn't come,
it wouldn't be as bad.
Like if a girl boy for the as time's up.
Oh so close.
Yeah,
that's better.
What we see.
If a girl's sucks your Dick and you're like,
Ooh,
well here's what I would do if I,
if I ever use this tonight checking rule,
obviously I would jerk off until the point of it goes down.
I'll do it right now.
Do it for nine seconds and then I'd fucking explode.
But you had a low pressure.
I mean,
you might not,
there's no pressure from me when it comes to come and there's nothing I'm going
to fucking,
I have,
I am the most disappointing person when it comes to sex.
I am fucking the worst.
I bet it's a lot of dudes out there that are up in arms right now.
They'll tell you they're more disappointed than you know,
I it because when you get back,
you know,
you don't do
it for so long when you're married,
you know,
two weeks,
three weeks,
whatever.
And you know,
we'd rather,
you know,
do you want to do it to,
and I just get a snack,
a whatever,
you know what I mean?
And it's just not,
we don't love each other.
Just man,
what the fuck?
So then it builds up,
you know,
the fucking build up,
and then I just go,
tell me one dumb story of you fucking a professor or anything and then boom,
what do you think you're gonna use your nine seconds on?
If you got to pick the girl,
are you going to go like old and black?
Are you going to go young?
And Red Eye.
He's gotta be uncut,
cut,
bushmen leaves over his Dick.
Not put the spirit down.
It's all good.
Like the best way for fucking for me.
And I don't know how I got this is from behind.
That's your best way.
Yeah.
Well you don't come as quick.
You don't have to look at the person,
you know that it's kind of like,
it's a good animalistic.
Yeah.
It's more as parking.
It's more control.
Like,
you know,
huh?
You can imagine it's a guy not,
let's not get crazy.
I'm not Norton.
Uh,
so whatever.
So the whole time.
So we hear this thing that you said about Tom and Christian.
We don't know them.
I,
we see your name,
tennis against them and that,
now I'm starting to think about this roast battle.
Uh,
I'm kind of liking that other idea of the roast battle.
A great double team,
you know,
uh,
I'll be great as long as you pick the judges.
Roast battle.
Yeah.
It's very dependent upon judges.
You gotta make sure you get actual comics as judges get no,
well not some friend of someone that sneaks on or someone's grandfathered in and
you gotta you gotta make sure you get good.
That's like,
that's a big part of roast battle because it makes sure you get good judges.
Yeah,
no,
I went the other night to the store and Jeff Goes,
you want to,
uh,
help.
Help does perfect at it.
Yeah.
It's a goddamn great show.
When they do that Rose Battle in those guys jump up.
When someone nails somebody,
those guys jump up and do their,
their dances and oh my God,
it was funny.
They had a suicide bomb once with a,
the guy run down,
he had a vest on,
pressed a button,
some things flew up.
They got confetti to flies through the air.
I mean,
they do some wild shit.
It's a great guy,
Dan Bunco.
It's a good idea.
It's very fun.
You know,
they've had people write articles about it,
like negative articles about it because they'll say anything like,
all bets are off.
It is the fucking nastiest show in Hollywood.
But that's what you know going in.
It is fiction.
Okay.
And part of comedy sometimes is saying really low,
fucked up,
racist,
homophobic,
sexist shit.
And they clued including men,
whites to blacks,
blacks to whites,
women to men.
It's the most hurtful cutting shit you can say.
And everybody knows what you're doing.
Everybody knows that's the jokes.
That's how roasts are set up.
And they even had the race just guy in the corner were white table,
but he's,
what's his name?
Earl can go Whitney rice
playing characters.
They're playing racist characters.
People have like complained about it and wrote blogs about it.
We should find who those fucking people are and ban them for every comedy club
in the country.
Who Fuck you.
How can you get it?
How can you not exactly.
Well,
how can you pretend that what that is is you know that these are real statements
are looking to comedy central roasts.
Some of the most vile things are said,
but just because his comedy central,
they can get away.
And I,
I'm for comedy central roast.
Take that multiply by five and that's roast battle like literally the next one's
going to be amazing.
Kimberly condom versus PDC.
Pete's going down peanuts in deep truck hymns four and zero and I think Pete
might be one in five or something.
That pizza monster.
It's in one in five means he won one time.
Yes.
I said sports.
Give me a quote
on the team.
Next one.
The two guys you other night.
They both were I think four.
No,
that's the first time I've ever went to it.
One was Indian and one with some slop,
but sloth,
I mean just big fat guy.
But he was fun.
They had some great lines.
Were you there too?
I watched it on periscope.
Yeah,
they have some good fucking line.
It's a joke writing thing.
I mean that's really what it is.
It's a great show though.
It's perfect length go.
It's like an hour long,
you know,
it's amazing.
It was a lot of fun.
Hanging out.
Door is on fire right now.
Last night.
Okay.
Last night it was two shows,
two sold out shows in the fucking belly room.
We do this.
Um,
we just started doing this Nicu Sif and I started doing this new material show.
When you go up there,
you have to do all your new shit.
Like you can't do any established jokes if you've done a bit more than like,
I think we came up with a number like five to seven times.
It's like after that amount,
like it's over.
Like you can't do it anymore.
It's not new.
You know,
and we,
we had all these comics go up,
did that,
that was sold out.
Then there was a dollar show,
$1 to get him and it was all like a doorman.
All the doormen put together.
That was sold out to Dalea.
Did that show.
Then I go over to the main room and Bill Burr,
magical,
uh,
Bert Kreischer.
I went up there.
That was sold out too.
That was last night.
Yeah.
That was packed at the same time.
The ors got a show at the same fucking time and that's packed.
It was madness.
That's how that shakes.
They should've been for the,
like the last 20 years in Hawaii.
It was just magic.
Why you're the shit manager.
They got rid of the shit manager and exploded.
It had just flourish.
But how does it manage her death?
He is death.
He was just aids.
He was Ebola.
He was all the above.
He was a shit sandwich served to you on a fucking and the dog Dick Platter.
It was the worst.
Everybody avoided the guy.
I mean that was one of crusher was there last night for the first
time in 10 years.
Yeah.
He goes,
I'm never there because of that guy.
Yeah.
The guy who used to be the manager,
you know,
and now you know,
they've got Eric and they've got Adam from of the Tempe Improv and it's fucking
for next Wednesday I got Dane Cook on on a show,
which is crazy cause Jane grew up.
I like the laugh factory.
Never went to the comedy store is even more crazy.
You got them on,
cause there's a lot of crazy things in this world.
He,
last night he was,
uh,
I went out at the Improv.
That place was packed.
Hop and comedy.
Right now we were talking about this,
that comedy is probably right now in the golden age,
I think this is the golden age of standup comedy,
you know,
I mean last night at the fucking store that showed,
they did in the main room between magical and crusher and bill burr was hosting
it and we saw monster fucking show,
and I'm thinking about this,
I'm like,
look at how many great comics are are today.
It's,
it's amazing.
It's such a great time to watch comedy,
you know,
two amazing time.
There's so many good,
great comics and just New York and La.
Are those the two hubs?
Big epicenters?
Yeah.
I mean you go in New York and there'll be a line up and you're like,
whoa.
You know what I mean?
I looked at the standard line up.
It was Depaulo when Ari,
a bunch of other fucking killers.
It's like you're getting this like in these two places especially,
and other states can do it.
You know,
like Boston of course used to have,
it doesn't really have it anymore,
but it could come back or books come back be fucking when they had all those
Roger Sinden tingle and monsters.
Gavin and Lenny and,
and uh,
you know,
what's his name?
Kevin Knox.
Oh,
you mean Barry Crimmins looking monster murder.
Murder row.
Steve Sweeney monsters.
Don Gavin months sweet.
I've never seen somebody killed.
Like I've seen Gavin and Sweeney kill back there or Roger sent back.
Those people don't know.
They weren't there back then.
Those guys,
man,
they,
there was a new existed in a bubble and they never left.
They never left town.
And because they never left town,
they fucked themselves.
They never developed a draw on the road.
They never,
you got to go to a place and you got to go to a place once and then he got to
come.
Then people go,
oh,
rich vos is back.
And then again,
and it takes fucking years to develop a crowd.
Well,
all show to those guys in Boston made so much fucking money.
They didn't have to leave to get paid and coke.
They were,
I was doing coke packet when I used to go up there and that was part of the
problem there.
There was a lot of coke up there.
There was a lot of fucking coke.
That's hard to get paid and coke and Oregon.
What am I doing here with this check?
I did a fucking,
uh,
I did a show,
a show at a one night or in Scranton.
It was me and Sandler.
He was Medellin and I was a one night or,
and uh,
the owner took us into back and you know,
I guess he was getting 70,
and then maybe I was getting 90 or 68,
whatever.
Right.
Show the owner pulls out just fucking right.
I mean,
and says you guys want any token Shay or money.
And I had and said,
no.
I said,
fuck yeah,
right.
I probably got two and a half ago,
I got double the money,
the in coke
at,
you know,
at least cause she would go sell a coke or just do it.
Did I sell it?
I had intentions to sell it.
Yes,
like all the other times I had big,
big bags of coke,
coke.
Did you ever take coke and cut it with like,
yeah,
I had.
What I do is tie.
Oh Man,
this is,
I told you this story.
This dude came up from Florida front of ours and he brought three ounces.
I'm talking fucking some of the best coke ever.
How big is an ounce of coke?
It's 28 grams.
No.
Is it like a six,
eight years?
It was,
no,
it's 28 1660 ounces a pound.
How many ounces is 20 it's
28 grams is okay.
It's 2021 grams of that movie where they say the soul.
Okay.
I might make a mistake on words.
You don't know Graham metrics system or you can tell him sooner.
What is it?
Okay,
so it was 20 I meant what does it look like?
But what does the,
I guess maybe this month
and he pulls that much coke.
No,
I don't know.
It's like a bag,
you know she's doing in between your fingers.
Oh,
okay.
Oh that much.
Yeah.
That's a lot.
That seems like a lot.
Yeah.
It's like an eight ball,
right?
Are you talking about 28 and eight announce or an April?
What's anything?
It's three and a half grand.
Oh wait,
three and a half grams.
What did,
what are you showing us,
Jamie?
Which ones announced on your point of reference?
Yeah.
No,
that's not,
that's a quarter.
What does that thing on the scale,
what does it say on the scale?
The far right.
Far Right.
What does that say?
Two ounces.
Anyhow,
there we go.
So do I.
You asked if I could go.
Wow.
That's a lot.
It's a lot.
That's amazing.
Okay,
so you had two ounces of coke.
Now my friend came up with three ounces,
three ounces of two or three hours.
I mean,
fucking is,
it's good as you can get.
Uh,
and my mother was gone for a weekend.
Somehow we were in my building and people are,
we're selling coke like it's crazy.
Right?
And smoking it just fucking free base and,
and cooking.
And He fell asleep.
He fell asleep.
And I,
you know,
I can tell you a couple of stories.
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you two other ones are funny.
He fell asleep and I took his fucking coke.
No,
I pulled it out from under that we had and I took three and a half and eight out
and I put an eighth of lactose in which you can't even tell the difference.
This coke was so strong and you know I took like three and a half grams it has.
But here's the fun.
Two funny stories.
One time my friend said,
get me an eight to coke,
three and a half grams and stick it under my door and you can have a half a
gram,
whatever.
So I left three grams under his door while I did it.
I went back,
smoked my half A.
I said,
hey.
And I,
I went back to his place and I took a hangar and I pulled it back out.
I made about five trips there
at the end.
It was just lactose.
Okay,
so now,
so now here's another story.
This fucking Guy John,
I was under road doing comedy.
He hasn't seen me.
He goes,
look man,
I haven't seen a woman.
I'm going to buy an eighth or coke.
Okay,
so that's three and a half grams.
It cost him $250,
right?
He goes,
we're going to do a gram,
which leaves two and a half grams left.
Uh,
that helps sell for a hundred,
150 but he actually cut it in five half grams.
That'll sell 55 half grams to get us 250 back.
And we have a gram that will smoke together.
He goes,
I senior,
I'll smoke.
So we smoked a Graham,
there's two and a half grams left that he's going to sell to get his money back.
He falls asleep.
Okay.
I don't know how I found out where he hit it,
so I would,
okay.
I would go in his fuck where he hit it and take a half a gram out.
Did I would drive to the store and buy a pneumonia,
ammonia ammonia,
is it ammonia or pneumonia?
I don't want to fuck this up.
Ammonia.
And he had to be clear and I would cook it.
There's a way to cook it.
So I go there,
I buy a bottle,
come back,
cook a half a gram,
smoke it,
pour out all the ammonia,
right?
And I'm no fucking,
and now I can eat.
You can make crack.
You can make freebase with him.
All right,
so I fucking,
I took,
I took off.
He says his first,
the first half,
agree with them.
Rene's or in business.
His first half crab,
I went to the store,
bought the ammonia,
cooked the half a gram,
poured the ammonia out so I wouldn't steal anymore and fucking smoked it.
I can't stop
fucking I'm backups.
I made five trips to the convenience store,
bonding among
right.
And I'm so fucking whacked out and fucked up and all the guys go,
why does this guy keep coming in every hour?
But I go,
look,
I got a cleaning business right just to use.
A lot of them are so all of a sudden he wakes up and I hear,
I hear now,
I'm no coke left.
I'm drinking pure straight vocat to try.
And all I hear is a big fuck him yelling upstairs.
Where's Mike?
He came down,
where's my coke?
I go,
look,
don't worry.
I sold it for you while you were sleeping on credit to this guy.
I stole.
I paid him back but I just stole it.
I was a scumbag.
I was a drug addict.
That's a lot of cocaine.
You were doing the vodka to calm your body down because you're all whacked out.
I was so funny.
I had a and then and there was nothing worse than when sun up sun up.
I'm walking home
all fucking coming down.
No one,
I have no money.
Nothing.
It was the worst fucking it.
It was the worst life on the plan.
It was such a bad life,
you know?
And then the running would,
you know in to New York,
what is it most feel like that you have to drink vodka.
Like what?
What is like,
you're just so calm.
Your body down,
you're just going to explode.
It's like being really high on caffeine and then alcohol kind of takes you down
a few notches.
Like slows you down.
It counteracts it.
Yeah.
It's just,
I don't know.
You never snorted coke.
He never did coke.
And you're like,
no,
get out of here.
Really?
No,
no.
Did it.
Oh Wow.
Have you done coke?
Oh,
of course.
Yeah.
No saw way too many people just lose their,
lose their shit.
Did you do snow?
You ever smoke it?
So you know how fucking the rush and the problem is,
and it's not,
I'm not glorifying smoking.
It gives you more of a rush.
Kidding me.
I didn't think that smoking it.
That's where you just like,
oh,
heart pounding clean.
It's a rush that you'll never ever the first one.
You'll won't repeat it till maybe a day later.
So you keep trying to chase that fucking debt.
First hit my friend Johnny.
This is back when we,
when I lived in New York,
it was the real time square.
Like Times Square was a real thing.
Like you go to Times Square,
there was Pete boots,
it was dirty.
It was a dangerous spot.
He would go,
he would smoke crack and he'd go to Times Square and you go to those peep booths
and he would,
uh,
he would beat off in these people who was like forever.
And he goes,
you didn't even come.
He just just kept playing with yourself.
But you just kept watching porn and watching girls like finger themselves in
front.
And he go and I go,
what?
They look like.
They were fucking disgusting.
It didn't matter.
It was just that it was deviant.
You would just do it.
It's like for whatever reason,
the smoking crack made them just want to do dirty shit.
Just do,
just be a dirty naughty person.
You know?
I was smoking so much one night and like did shriveled up so much.
I couldn't,
and I look at my pants,
I was so fucking,
I couldn't,
I thought it went into my body.
I feel like I lost it completely sucked
and I'm gone.
And Coke.
Yeah,
well you took Calc II.
Yeah.
And if I don't like,
like I was so fucked up,
I go,
is it,
oh,
I'll deal with it later.
I'm going to get high.
But I thought my fucking Dick was him.
We used to go to this fucking people.
It was funny,
one night,
God,
I think we've told the story on the ONA,
but like in Philly to which these fucking people's on the way home from Philly
and you'd go in and you would pay a girl to watch you Kericho off.
Right.
And she would like,
she's now couldn't touch you,
but she wants to maybe go,
ah,
Ooh,
you know,
uh,
but you've got to do it in front of somebody.
So it was fucking great.
Don't look at it.
Me Is so exciting.
So one time,
I mean,
Norton and all of us used to go,
but one time it was me,
Levy and Florentine.
So Florentines,
Jim,
Florence and Bob Bob's who Florentines in the booth first in one at a Boosie and
he's on,
all of a sudden,
I swear to God,
you hear over the loudspeaker mop to booth for right to fucking clean up his
jazz.
And then,
and then you find out your buddies,
the booth for like,
so no,
they fucking Levy.
Now there's curtains on the door,
you know there's a shade,
but there's this much space.
So Levy's in the room where we could see the shadow of a fucking hand flying
back and forth,
right?
We can see the shackle of his hand jerking himself off fucking clue or under the
chain.
And this hand was moving fucking fast.
I've never seen somebody Jared off that fucking ass.
How many times he's seen guys jerk off
and my database,
most of over a lifetime of observing how well,
you know,
I said judge,
I study and then one time we went in there and meet Norton and I got kicked out
cause I was trying to negotiate with the girl.
I go,
look,
what the fuck?
Just take $15 what the fuck?
You know,
I'm,
you don't have to do nothing but sit in and watch.
We'll they supposed to take 25 and that was a lot of money back then.
You have to these one nighters.
I go take 15 and I got kicked out,
keep negotiating.
Sometimes I got him down,
but I got kicked out and fucking Norton walks out the car and goes,
how could you possibly get kicked out of a peep booths?
How can you get kicked out of up?
How fucked up is your life that you got kicked out of a peep booths and this is,
Norton was totally sober back then.
Like we were all born.
Well Norton was,
he only did drunk.
So there was like 18 or something like that.
Yeah,
he got sober like really young.
It's kind of crazy.
Think about it.
Like you realize that I can't do,
I can't do this anymore.
He was fucked up.
Did you ever hear the central park story with me in northern?
No.
Oh,
this is a class
the side.
Can we go,
he told this story to crack my fingers.
Okay.
We,
uh,
we're coming out of somewhere,
maybe a 12 step meeting or whatever,
you know,
so,
and there's hot,
hot black chick walks by and recognizes me from,
and I wasn't even maybe from a cop.
I didn't,
maybe I did one TV show or two when my life,
so I shipped to her,
do you want to go out for,
for Bagels,
were going for bagels.
She said,
okay.
So we went ahead bagels.
Then we said,
hey,
we're going to go uptown to the Pete Boosie,
you know,
on like 54th whatever.
Broad look.
Go look.
I'm not trying to judge a prostitute.
I'm not fucking judging people.
We're not here to judge.
But I mean,
did you know she was a prostitute?
She wasn't a prostitute,
but use a fighter to a Pete booth.
Yeah,
we are.
She's already likes us.
We got go.
She gotta fuck you already got her.
She already got a fucking free Bagel south.
We're not thinking this is going to be a girlfriend someday.
No,
no,
no.
But you got to,
so it's hilarious.
So we go,
hey,
we're gone.
We were planning on it.
I mean,
ordering up there.
Anyhow,
so we go up to the quarter moon to people and she comes into a booth when me
and,
but we get kicked out the fucking Indian fucking get out,
you know?
No couple,
no scalpel,
no couple's into booth in those quarter boots.
You can't bring somebody in.
So now there's just no fucking lie.
I'm not lying.
We're standing right across from the Ed Sullivan Theater.
Right.
And there's like a,
a newspaper Kiosk and we're leaning on a car and I'm making out with her and,
and,
and I'm fingering her on Broadway.
So she fucking and nortons just grabbing her ass like a little fucking like,
he's like,
it's a toy.
He's playing with her.
Right.
So I faint and she comes right.
She has an orgasm standing on Broadway from briefing.
So then we'd get in the car,
we go,
hey,
Julian has an orgasm.
Who Does?
Allegedly,
no,
I had no idea to tell.
You could feel it.
Hunter.
Well she didn't piss on my finger,
but you can,
but you can tell when a goal is hazard.
If she wasn't faking it,
she wasn't in a Raj.
Okay.
Sell was in Hawaii.
Now I'm not saying it was the best one that Sean has been tardy.
You're fingering her.
She said,
no,
I didn't know my stubby little fingers know what they're doing.
Okay,
but you're being Nikki negative.
This is
just trying to get a real clear picture of what actually happened.
Okay.
Could it be any clearer?
You're fingering her.
That must have looked like a site also,
by the way.
Just talk back and they heard in the middle and then Norton grabbing the bud.
Yeah,
it'll confirm all of that.
So then we go,
let's take a ride up to central park and we were walking through central park
and then she's blowing me,
right.
She's blowing me.
And,
and then I looked down and I,
she Norton eating her ass
little kid in candy.
Right.
And I'm trying not to crack up because I'm fucking blown.
You don't want to fucking laugh as you getting blown.
Right.
You know?
But this has got to feel good for her.
She's getting her assay and,
and,
and now I'm getting blown.
So I shoot a load,
we get back in the car and we're driving and I,
I go to north and you have a good time.
He goes,
wow.
I was a little uncomfortable.
I got my,
my,
my pants dirty.
I go,
you'll fucking eat out.
A strange girls,
they ass,
but you're worried about getting your fucking pants.
What are you going to get home?
Your mom's going to say,
look at these grass stains.
Were you eating out?
Asked again.
It like he was upset that he grass stains on his pants.
I,
she was eating fucking strange girl.
So hilarious.
That's so,
sounds like Norton too.
It's so ridiculous.
We,
I mean this is,
I was obviously single and young weekish so fuck,
you know,
he,
I was dating this girl that was so fucking hot and we're in a car and she was
blowing in,
Norton was walking by.
I go,
hey,
you want to watch?
And he,
he goes,
yeah,
he comes in and he's in the back of the car.
She didn't cause he's just fucking,
you know,
we picked up this fucking jerking off.
She calls,
she's blown.
Yeah.
But I come so quick,
he goes,
fuck man.
Hole off.
Uh,
so
one time we pick up this hottie I pick out,
it's always made picker.
I picked up,
just go off onto the commie.
I'm fucking so we're going back to Norton's house
and she's blowing me.
And whatever and nortons Turk and off and next thing you know,
I see a load fly and hit Norton in the fucking head from you.
Like he fucking blowing me.
He,
he jerked and a fucking,
I don't know why it gets so,
yeah,
he hit himself in the head and I was so fucking impressed that as soon as that
high and hit himself and then I was like,
it was fucking very impressive.
Okay.
John,
he's a creep.
What about you?
I'm not,
I'm just getting blown.
I didn't do anything DVN I didn't do anything wrong.
He's so honest about his perversions.
It's hilarious.
I was there ever been a guard on the radio?
That's is is honest about its perversions as Norton.
I don't even think there's a close second.
No,
no one like a regular radio guy that's as honest about being a pervert and
trannies and all the crazy shit that Norton does.
I mean,
that's very unique that,
you know.
Yeah.
I think opie and Anthony when they were together brought really w we're good to
get the truth out of all of us from Tollin to fucking Bobby.
I mean,
we spilled our guts and Patrice,
Patrice,
I mean really have told stories that,
you know,
I mean that are like really fucking deep about our parents and upbringing,
you know.
Uh,
and that's what people think.
They know it.
That's why I hate fucking somebody guys on Twitter.
They,
they think they're just,
cause we,
you're not my friend.
Don't ever,
you know,
so you can't say that things Norton and,
and Bobby and Patrice and whatever [inaudible] say to me,
that's why they think,
but Chris,
they got so they know so much about our lives,
but Norton brings you to a whole nother level.
Like you say,
like,
you know what I mean?
Like,
uh,
you know,
had I known,
you know what I mean?
I did get,
we'll even thinking about it.
Cause it's lucky it every,
you know,
every,
uh,
there's nobody.
Like Norton Norton is a completely unique individual and always has been,
you know,
always husband.
He's just,
we just found his voice more as a comic,
you know,
now than ever before.
But he's always been this like really unique guy.
Well,
I,
I can tell you what he does.
I don't watch a lot of comics stand up.
I just don't watch a lot.
Once in a blue moon,
I'll see a little of this,
a little of that.
But on radio,
there was no one quicker.
I come back then Norton,
no,
no.
Hands down.
He is,
he's my favorite all time radio personality.
uh,
he's in,
he,
uh,
he's in,
I know him as a f I'm just saying he's quick as fuck.
Oh radio.
He's in his class by himself.
But that also too,
when you're going in there,
you know,
if Collins in and Bobby and me and when Patrice was there,
your go walking into the lion's den,
you gotta be,
you know,
boom.
There's no fucking,
I mean we will just tear fucking Patrice.
And he laid into me.
He first,
he attacked my,
I had a Rolex,
somehow he attacked me having a Rolex.
Okay.
Cause it wasn't a brightening.
It was a Rolex where I bought a frog.
Brian,
I can get a deal Rolex to him it was,
he's,
you know,
black guys don't,
they liked those big fucking,
you know,
then he attacked me.
He attacked me,
you know what I'm saying,
from acids to watch this.
So Denny,
he attack.
I had,
I was driving at the time a Porsche Boxster,
right?
A dumb,
and he had a,
I think a cattle escalate or whatever,
and he was calling me selfish.
So I'm driving this little car and he's killing me and I,
and I'm driving home from Ona and I can't let,
I'm going,
wait,
you fucking fat.
Fuck,
you're driving to escalate.
That's fucking,
uh,
you know,
using all this gas,
all this,
you know,
I'm not just,
you're the selfish one because you could not stop eating fucking fruitcakes and
now so,
and then he's saying how crappy my car,
two days later,
I,
I'm online looking at the price of a Boxster new against his car,
new and all the stats.
And I fucking email it to him because he calls me cracking up.
It's,
so he goes,
you're still thinking about this.
You're still thinking about this.
I walked out of studio,
I forgot it was,
it was radio,
but it was,
he fucked with you.
He fucking rip me down so hard and I quit and he,
he was overpowered.
Patrice was an and power and guy.
We,
even if you were right,
you couldn't,
he just does so verbally overpower.
You know how big he would be today if he was a cop as a combo,
he'd be,
he's hands down would be,
he'd be right up there with anybody or done any of the biggest comics in the
world today as talent was.
He did sabotage a lot because,
well,
not,
no,
he didn't,
not,
I'm wrong.
He didn't,
he knew what he wanted.
He turned down a lot.
He didn't sabotage it.
W what kind of stuff that he turned down?
Well,
I mean,
you know,
Spike Lee liked him,
but I guess the money wasn't right what he was offered,
you know,
for a movie or for whatever to do whatever would spike day when,
when puffy had that show on,
uh,
Hbo,
whatever.
It wasn't Deb Cam was another black comic thing.
They asked him to host it and he,
I,
he didn't like the deal.
He turned it down.
Uh,
when he had VH one,
I think he wanted his own billboard in Times Square and some more,
you know,
whatever.
Well he deserved it.
He deserved and they said No.
So I was like,
fuck you then.
But whatever he was offered,
but he knew what he wanted.
He was offered many rows before he did that.
Uh,
Charlie Sheen one and he was right.
He's going,
why am I going to do a fucking roast with DC comics that aren't in my league and
are not my friends?
Well he wasn't either talking about who's the best at that road.
He's like,
who are they going?
Who was named Charlie Sheen?
Was that the most?
And,
and,
and just on that can we're on it.
And he murdered and he let me tell you,
he went last and a lot of that with this,
that was ad,
cause I went over a lot of his stuff before we taught.
You know what I mean?
So I go and,
and stuff was hit and then he started getting mad because you're talking about
his diabetes and he's like,
what the fuck?
It ain't or talk about me like this.
You know?
And that was his whole mindset before you even going into the roast.
So they multiply the by saying shit about,
cause he goes,
they're not my fucking friends.
They don't,
you know what I mean?
And he clearly stole that roast.
Clearly hands down would a fucking from there,
there would've been no stopping Patrice.
None so sad.
You know,
it's,
it's so fucked up that some of the funniest guys have all these self sabotaging
traits like bad diet drugs not taking care of themselves as so,
so,
so fucking sad.
But he was a baby.
I know he wasn't a drug addict.
He didn't drink.
He didn't do,
was body,
didn't take care of his dying to me.
I'd fucking diabetes and take care of it.
He thought he died from something that other people haven't died from.
I mean,
if he just lost weight and eat healthy and started eating vegetables,
could have lowered his blood sugar.
Are,
you could have dealt with it in a healthy way,
but,
but what makes a guy that fucking funny?
It's kind of the same shit that I don't give a fuck attitude.
You can't have that.
I don't give a fuck attitude and be,
you know,
drinking green tea instead of eating cheeseburgers.
You know?
It's like,
it comes with the lifestyle.
It's a lifestyle.
He,
she,
there's con,
there's comics that,
that do comedy from their head and their funders,
funny guy,
he came from,
to me the best comics on the planet are comics or talk from their heart that
talk from
within them.
You know what I mean?
You're not,
they didn't figure it out.
They lived it or they experienced it.
You know what I'm saying?
So Patrice wasn't,
he was brilliant.
He had to think of it,
but it really came from here.
This was how he,
he was in real life that,
you know,
he didn't go on stage and hey,
let me do my fucking act.
Right.
You know,
and a good comic,
you know,
uh,
you take like Louie and Stan hope and,
and Voss.
You take guys like that.
You thought,
you know what he said in Ventura comedy club Friday this Friday to Sun,
California,
Ventura,
Ventura harbor.
Holy Shit.
No,
but you see what I'm saying?
You taught,
you take these guys like Stan Hope,
I think is fucking a genius.
I think he's just at a whole nother level.
I read some of his blogs and just a guy who's awesome,
his fucking mind.
He said,
well,
he's really live in it.
You know what I mean?
Like Stan hope lives in Bisbee,
Arizona in the middle of fucking nowhere in a multicolored like bright orange
house,
uh,
or blood bright yellow house.
He has a Superbowl parties.
He invites the world,
literally gives out his address on my podcast and it says,
come to my Superbowl party.
So he has hundreds of people.
He has no idea who they are flying in to Tucson then drive to Bisbee and show
up.
But it's fucking house and he lets them inside where he sleeps and eats and are
wander around and starts drinking smoking and he doesn't give a fuck you like,
like there's a lot of guys pretending to not give a fuck.
Yeah.
Stan hope is that guy,
you know,
wearing those ironic suits.
Oh.
And he's like,
I kind of have to stop wearing these because other people,
I think I'm serious.
You know like people like and now like wearing ironic close is become like
ironic suits is become like a thing that people can sit closer to.
Almost like a hipster thing.
I watched him at a show,
I think he was doing with Norton and Artie Lange and tell it Atlantic city we
went down to hang out.
I like,
it could have been a bright yellow fucking blazer.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean you would think he was going to introduce acrobats.
Okay.
Yeah.
We,
yeah,
that gives a burlesque emcees.
We did the end of the world show,
the December 21st,
2012 showed at the alternatives,
a honey honey,
Joe Diaz,
Stan hope and millions to tell,
pour this ridiculous suit.
It was just ridiculous.
Was half of what made it awesome.
It was him.
He was fucking stupid suit.
But his,
his mind like houses get a photo,
his house,
he's got look at his house.
I mean,
if anybody wants to visit Doug,
Stan hope you can't miss it.
Just drive through Bisbee of fighting in five seconds ago.
Oh,
there he is.
But what I also,
what I love about him,
he calls his own shots and there's business.
Oh,
you know what I mean?
And He,
I mean,
first guys to do these promotions where he was like,
you know,
I'm tired of working at these comedy clubs and they give me shit money and I
know how much I'm bringing in.
That's his house.
That's fucking,
that's his,
as his house.
That's what you want to see on the Internet to somebody made from a,
uh,
from an x car.
Go,
uh,
you know,
pebbles instead of a lawn,
we'll get all these,
this is a,
this is just a bunch of people probably that's like a part,
probably a party that he,
that's a fuck halfway house.
So yeah,
that's cool party.
But I mean he has the Super Bowl parties and I dunno if all of them are photos.
There's other photos where there's even more pictures that looks like an x
storage bin.
Like one of those things that is podcast down there.
What does that scroll down a little,
because he has a podcast now.
Is that the studio?
Click on it.
Let me see that.
The one with the podcast.
Yeah.
Oh look at that.
They can go.
Who's that with him?
I said girl.
No,
the other Guy Quinn from impractical jokers.
So that's his,
he's got his own podcast studio now.
Good for him.
And that's all in,
in his wacky house.
I fucking,
he's a maniac.
I fucking love the fact that he takes like goes into rock,
does what he wants to do.
I love fucking Combo.
Do comedy clubs now because he's undeniable now.
They have to give him the door or whatever the fuck the deal is.
They do weekend,
he'll do a Tuesday,
Wednesday in a comedy club that wants to do a weekend.
I'll do what we can.
But it's,
it's one of those things where they were trying to tell him what he was worth
and he was like,
why am I giving you guys anything?
And I can just sound out a rock club.
The problem those rock clubs is we saw him once in La,
we went to see him in La.
You have to stand up.
It was a concrete floor.
You're standing.
And after like a half hour,
I was like,
this is the last,
I'm never going to do a standing room.
Cause I had done a few standing shows.
I'm like,
I'm never doing one of these ever again.
We went down to watch him and Philly do one of those things and it's kind of
uncomfortable standing Sally's bullshit.
Bullshit.
I mean,
hey stuff.
You got to talk into the microphone where had earphones your phone,
Mr. Microphone for one second.
You know,
look at everybody's not perfect.
Uh,
but I do know how many grams in the fucking announce when I'm saying,
okay,
as you know,
working smartest guy,
Ventura,
where's it benchmark?
Uh,
but his act,
what I've seen of him,
he doesn't have to,
like,
some comics really have to connect with he,
he's so smart and brilliant.
He could do his act laying down on a couch with his head.
Do you know what I do?
You get what I'm saying?
Like he's so smart.
I think he's so smart as a person that you could listen to him and you don't
have to see him to get what he's saying.
You're not a comedy album.
No.
No,
but I'm saying you're saying a comedy club.
What people are sitting down.
So focus,
you know,
when I do stand up,
a lot of times I'll sit on the direct tension right on the,
you know,
focused,
right?
But someone like me,
I can't,
I,
he is just so smart debt all you could close your eyes and listening to what
he's saying.
Go on.
This is some brilliant shit.
[inaudible] that doesn't make sense.
A marathon,
he's brilliant.
I don't know what you're saying now.
You're not really doing a good job of tall book is you're saying you,
you,
you the standing,
the standing up,
he would do better sitting down.
Oh,
that's not what I said.
I meant when you're in the audience.
Yeah.
It's uncomfortable to stand for a long period of time and I'll never do a
standing show where the audience has to stand because they're not comfortable.
They don't enjoy it the way you enjoy it.
If you could sit down and relax,
but you're saying if it's not comfortable,
then you're not taking in everything that's being said because you're not
comfortable.
No.
Yeah.
I mean it's just,
I mean,
that's comes in a car.
It's not as good as an experience because discomfort is a part of the
experience.
Instead of just being to,
if you're sitting down watching a show,
you can just concentrate on the show,
but 45 an hour and a half into a show and you're standing for that whole time,
your feet start to hurt.
They'll do that for a rocker end.
Yeah.
I bet you're dancing around and stuff.
Like my legs were locked into the point where I felt like I was almost about to
fall over.
I don't know what my point was.
The fucking guy,
he's brilliant.
Oh,
he's definitely brilliant.
I don't even think he does standing shows anymore.
I don't think it doesn't mind,
but most people have abandoned them all you all it takes is being an audience
member wants and he'd go,
oh well fuck this.
You know?
That's why I stopped doing the House of Blues in Vegas.
They used to have that fucking standing part on the side.
Oh that's the worst.
Do you have the seated part?
Which was awesome.
And then they have the top seating.
Awesome.
But then they'd have to,
bar area was filled with people just standing and it was fucking terrible.
It was terrible.
It's like they would talk like he would literally,
you would have like,
I would like be trying to do standup at a nightclub.
Like when there's a full on like bar scene happening and you know,
attention everyone just like you're interrupting conversations instead of,
if you go to a comedy club,
everybody seated the show starts and that they're there to see a comedy club.
There's too much,
too much room for variables.
Some comedy clubs you like,
I've done some rooms like in casinos,
whatever where the sheets are too comfortable and now they're too fucking
relaxed and you know the,
those cushion seats and they're laying back and are not couches are not good for
calming.
No,
you can't be too comfortable.
Haha.
Has couches in the front and it's like,
this is a little too goddamn casual to flux.
Is that an la and la?
Yeah,
it's a north Hollywood,
a smaller club.
So you can't be too comfortable.
You can't be too uncomfortable.
Like I went to,
um,
Sturgill Simpson did a cone and the other day and I went to watch and it's
fucking cold as shit in there.
They've got that thing going on.
Like Letterman likes to do.
Like we used to crank down the uh,
the temperature,
like way down,
like in the 60s.
Isn't that for the lighting?
The light bulbs.
But I think the idea behind Letterman was that when you were cold,
you will,
you have a little bit more energy.
You're more likely to laugh then if it's really hot,
it's really hot in the room.
People don't laugh as much.
It kind of makes sense.
Oh fuck.
I'm going to pass out dry
isis weekend.
She's going to fucking Touro Harbor Comedy Club in Ventura,
California at eight through Sunday.
Are you there on Sunday too?
Yeah.
Wow.
Well He,
I am happy,
but here's the problem.
Sunday day I was invited to play golf at Bel Air Comedy Bel Air Country Club.
Okay,
so I'm going to drive from Ventura to Bel Air.
That's like two hours.
No,
it happened.
How come some people tell me 40 minutes,
some team?
an hour.
It took me two hours from Ventura to what?
Shut Bayview.
Look it up on that question with traffic.
There's no traffic.
It's Sunday morning at 7:00 AM 7:00 AM you're adorable.
You're adorable.
You don't know.
Los Angeles,
7:00 AM there easily can be Sunday morning easily.
If you go to Orange County,
you might be stopped dead and you might be stopped dead on a highway at 7:00 AM
on the five take the five Sunday morning might be stopped dead.
Okay,
but I'm just saying the overpopulated place.
No,
I,
I get that side.
Look how beautiful it is.
It's like that in February.
Yeah,
it's perfect.
Perfect weather.
But you look at a distance,
people find out about it.
They move here.
They have cars,
they drive,
they go,
you know what?
I'm just going to get up seven o'clock in the morning.
Who is going to be up on Sunday morning?
Oh,
there's only 90 fucking million people live here.
Jesus Christ.
You really don't have to depress the person.
I was looking,
I was looking forward to my day at Bel Air when you can do it.
You just couldn't believe.
Well,
I gotta be there by like nine saw.
Leave at seven.
Yeah,
you'll be fine.
No,
it's fine.
It's an hour and 40 minutes.
40 minutes from Bel Air to Ventura County.
It's an hour and two minutes without traffic,
which is adorable.
Why don't they just say if you fly?
Yeah.
Fuck.
So how has that Ventura harbor,
if you'd done that before?
I've never done it.
I heard good things.
Yeah.
Uh,
or it's a good company.
Yeah,
but I've never been there.
Have you ever been there?
No better.
Some guy contacted me there from there I think.
But I mean,
how come like a guy like especially you when you're doing like weekend rooms,
go into San Diego
Tuesday,
Wednesday stuff.
You do what?
Do weekends too?
Yeah,
but some weekends,
but yeah,
mostly say Wednesdays.
Oh,
okay.
I love Santa Barbara.
Oh,
I love it up there.
Just a little bit further north.
That's chose my whipped favorite spots.
That's what I got my weight on it.
When I become like Dennis Miller becomes some old conservative man with a radio
show.
Who's Heather?
Santa Barbara.
He lives up there.
It was all the white people,
all white people.
They just rally on against Mexicans.
We fucking angry about black people up there.
Why you could do that anywhere,
do it.
I mean,
you can't do it exclusively.
It's you're,
you're preaching to the choir.
Everyone around you.
I mean,
this is like zero diversity.
Do you know San Jose is the number ones,
uh,
less amount of black people in the United States of America,
San Jose
and number two is San Francisco.
San Francisco is the least amount of black people in United States.
That doesn't make sense.
Well,
what does Oakland number one?
Oh yeah,
it,
it's all black people.
Um,
they all moved to Oakland.
They can't afford San Francisco and Oakland is now like,
they're like,
it's totally different now.
I've always thought San Francisco is really diversified.
Yeah.
With Asians.
Well,
a mindset is diversive in,
I mean,
San Francisco's the real estate is so fucking ridiculous now.
The tech boom has fucked that place up so bad.
The prices are just,
they don't make any sense like you would,
you'd be an asshole to buy a house in San Francisco now,
unless,
unless you've got like Elon Musk money and you don't give a fuck,
you'll spend three minutes.
I saw a house for $3 million and my jaw dropped.
I was like,
this doesn't make any sense.
This is a $400,000 house.
How is this $3 million?
A little shit.
Right.
It was just,
it was a house,
a nice house,
but it wasn't $3 million.
I mean,
it didn't make any sense.
Well,
I look at these people in New York,
they fucking get,
these apartments are crazy,
that are as big as this table for a fucking crazy.
I go,
are you,
all you have to do is move 20 minutes in into Jersey and you could buy a fucking
house.
You know,
I looked at the house apartments in New York for a bit.
There was a time where I was thinking about moving to New York.
Just like to mix things up,
you know?
Yeah.
But it just didn't make any sense.
And you know,
the,
you know,
one thing that gets me about New York is a,
the sets that you do around town,
they're real short.
You know,
everyone's doing like 15 minutes,
10 minutes.
I'm like,
that is not enough.
That's not enough time to really get busy.
But when you can,
you can,
you'd be able to do more time in places.
You know,
when rock walks in and he's not,
he's doing what he wants you to do.
When you know Sharon comics walk in,
you know,
Louie or whatever.
I'm sure you could do a half an hour.
They wouldn't have liked to walk into that.
I want to schedule that.
You know what I mean?
It's one of the reasons why I like doing the belly room and we do those weekends
at the belly room.
I could do 45 minutes in town on a Friday,
Saturday night,
you know,
like that.
Like you,
if you got to really hone your act,
I'm not working on one bit,
you know,
I'm working on six,
seven bits and trying to put together like a real hour for my next special and
if I'm doing a 10 or 15 minutes set,
there's just not enough time for that.
I,
and I don't want to do that whole trek around doing seven,
eight sets a night.
I just think that's what I wouldn't do that ever.
I do may never do one or two.
I never done.
I did it years ago in New York,
but I work out my material on the road.
You know Chris,
actually what?
I work it out and economy clubs because I'm going to have enough good stuff
around it.
If it doesn't work,
then the next one's Gunna,
when I know in New York when we were doing standup together,
I hardly ever did the city because I could do Connecticut or I could do long
island or could you jersey and I had make a 150 bucks.
Yeah.
You know,
I can make like real money get paid
versus if I was in town and I get 25 bucks here,
10 bucks there.
It's like what?
I'm not doing 10 sets a night to make $100 and it just seems so stupid because I
can't get roadwork or in the shitty bounce from club to club.
You know,
there's guys that do seven sets a night.
I could,
you know what,
getting a job on fucking Wall Street because there's no way there's old cock
suckers running around town.
But luckily I can work on the road.
And like you said,
you can work in DC,
Baltimore,
these are all driving distance where you could drive home Saturday night.
Right.
You know,
I tried call Philadelphia,
even Boston,
you know,
it's,
it's three and a half,
four hours,
whatever.
So you could do,
you could make a great living.
There's so much around there,
you know?
That's when I asked him,
like,
if,
you know,
you talked about San Diego,
well,
how are you not working at this other place if it's only an hour and a half away
on a weekend.
There was one place I used to work,
rooster t feathers or something,
or where's that?
I heard about that.
I went to fuck.
Is it,
you know,
that's still around?
Yeah,
I think so.
But a silicone valley,
we're still
the San Francisco area.
Yeah,
it's,
yeah,
it's something that got there.
Oh,
that's not driving distance from here that you could drive,
but it's going to be six plus hours.
That's too far.
But depending on traffic,
there's,
unlike La,
New York or Jersey where I live,
you could work fucking almost all year round and make a good living in weekend
common,
you know,
are you doing weekday gigs anywhere now?
We do a once in a while I'll get a private or a fundraiser,
you know,
like Tuesday night we'll do our radio show on Sirius and that's done.
We'll do a spot in the city here and there.
Cause you do on Tuesday series is in the city and the city in,
Oop,
we do oop studio me and do,
uh,
our radio show from seven and nine.
My wife hates me to radio show and so then I'll do a spot after it may be at the
cellar to hang out and or whatever,
uh,
you know,
and then Wednesday I probably will stay home cause I'm gonna leave Thursday,
Friday,
whatever,
you know.
So I try to be home Wednesday,
Sunday,
Monday,
Wednesday as much as I can if I got,
you know what I mean,
to be with my kid and,
and then I'll leave Sunday.
Uh,
you know,
once,
once in a blue moon on Wednesday night we'll go over to the stress factory on
open mic night and do some time cause it's 20 minutes from our house.
So we go,
well we want to work out something.
Why go into the city?
We just go to the open mic nights.
Just stretched out to the crowd or the stress factory on those nights.
Some nights it's crowded,
you know,
some nights it's tons of comics but it,
it's okay.
It's 20 we go there.
We took our kid on a Wednesday.
Not a lot of clubs in New Jersey.
Huh.
And stress factor.
That's all you really hear about bananas,
bananas and uh,
wherever I was at for
updates at point pleasant or something.
But that is in a shadow.
Their saddles are bananas in Poughkeepsie,
right,
isn't it?
Yeah.
What guides the other one's closed.
Closed.
Yeah.
Well where makes that Sushi place we did was that Jersey.
I remember it was like an old Chinese restaurant and some reason and it had a
weird stage,
like the stage look like a town or something.
And it was like a restaurant,
but they did comedy.
Well,
uncle Vinnie's does comedy.
When was this?
Five years ago.
It was me.
You,
Joey Diaz is,
I think,
well,
was it a Jesus,
Dave Sushi Dan?
It was like a Sushi restaurant and I was in New Jersey.
It was either new juice upstream and work.
No,
no,
you don't remember.
It was like a,
it was a restaurant in the stage.
Look like an a fake town.
Like it was a fake house.
He came out and look like you're on a front porch of a house or something,
right?
Oh No,
no,
no.
You're wrong.
That was a western Massachusetts.
That's a cha Chinese restaurant.
That's the Kooky Lau.
That's a for the comedy connection.
Yeah.
You do a,
you would do Friday night in the city and the new,
do you Friday night in Boston,
you do Saturday night out,
the Hooky Lau or Sunday,
the Hook Isla,
those death
has,
there's a place uncle Vinnie's chickopee.
That's what it was.
Ugliness.
But there's no liquor license.
It's bring your own beer or whatever.
You know,
they can't afford a liquor license.
But he gets big acts.
Dhea fuck it.
You can bring your own booze.
I guess they show up with a bottle of wine,
whatever wine.
And he does all way.
I mean,
just stretch factory obviously is the big club in directory.
Uh,
bananas brings him big acts,
you know,
they'll open the door.
Uh,
W I'm doing one in Boston.
It's a great new club in Boston.
A
Boston laugh boss.
I've done that.
I fucking love the fucking hotel is beautifully.
You stay right there,
right there.
Just come on down.
Come down.
The people that own it are great.
Recently.
It's,
he did,
what a fucking great gig.
Yeah.
You know,
I usually do the Wilbur,
but it was a,
somebody already had it.
It was a last minute thing because there was a UFC in Boston and uh,
I wasn't supposed to work here because there was a Fox sports one gig.
I usually do the,
uh,
either the paper views or the Fox gigs,
the Big Fox gigs,
but for whatever reason I wanted to do it or they wanted me to do it.
I forget how it worked.
And,
uh,
I had to do the lap pos and I had a great fucking time.
Yeah,
it's a great club,
right?
Yeah,
it's really good.
And they'll buy the restaurant surrounding the club,
you know,
whatever you want to do.
Too many good clubs.
It's so sad to go back and said,
well there's a little bit of a scene there now.
A lot of,
a little bit of a,
you know,
young comics coming up that are trying real hard that are,
trying to put together a scene.
But it takes decades to put together a scene like they used to have there.
It's amazing that it deteriorated the way it did and a big part of the reason
why I deteriorated as guys stopped writing,
they stopped writing.
Those guys are doing the same act for fucking decades.
Well No.
Was to club set didn't last.
I mean Nick,
why do you think they didn't last?
I mean there's a of that was that guy stopped writing.
It was I guess a real flower using the same guys and same guys,
same age.
It's still fun to watch.
But he had,
if he knew,
if you would go back to see Steve Sweeney every year and you knew he was going
to have a,
a new act,
that's like the one that you saw before.
Like I say,
if you went out and you could guarantee that you're going to see a half hour new
material from Sweeney and then a half hour of that old killer stuff that you
would love it.
But actually that's a good point.
All yeah,
I do blame a lot.
You're right.
The college back then because they didn't know what I mean with the Internet,
you can't do that.
You can't do that anymore.
So now everybody is doing the George Carlin method.
We tried to do a whole new special,
you know,
between a year and a year and a half,
two years depending on,
you know how you feel like some guys think that a year is too soon,
the material's not good enough and some guys think you know that your waste
waste time developing.
We should just move on to the next act and in five minutes,
Kathy Griffin,
we'll have another hour,
five minutes.
It tells you what you put down an hour every two hours or every two hours.
She puts out a lot of hours out,
but she's not lying with her and telling jokes.
A lot of them are stories,
stories about her hanging out with share and stuff like share stuff,
returning her call.
She lose half of our act.
Uh Gee.
I tried to do,
that's what the people love the town they called us.
I tried to do it at a new CD every two years.
Every two years I tried to do a new sheet.
Yeah,
two years is a good time because that means you work on it for a solid year and
a half and then the last six months you just fucking sharpening that sword sheet
and then by the time it comes around you're filming,
you're sick of it.
You don't want to do that anymore.
I add and take out,
add and take out.
Like I know like I think like Chris,
I've seen Chris,
I think maybe even lily does it.
Like I'll see Chris go on it shaved with a whole note.
You know,
he's trying to do a whole new half or 45 at once.
Get it all together.
You know,
I throw it in a new bit,
drop a bit,
throwing a new bit,
drop a bit.
But some of these fucking guys like Louie and critter fucking naked,
just write an hour like he wrote for Chris.
You helped him right when he was doing like some of the specials,
right?
No,
I wrote,
I was,
when he did it on the Oscars,
I wrote his last movie,
top five.
I wrote on that.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
I helped to punch up,
Eh,
and s Chris was smart.
He had a couple of times he,
you know,
Depaulo topology.
Paul was in on the movie.
He was on the Oscars.
Yeah.
Oscars.
And
yes,
when we did the Oscars fucking Jenny,
you know,
the problem with a lot of big comics and you're going to is that they can be,
a lot of people aren't honest with them.
Everybody,
when
you get you a shirt level has a lot of yet.
Yeah.
That's great.
That's,
yes.
Yeah.
No,
you could do it.
And it's really not to their standard.
And when we wrote on the Oscars,
Jenny had no problem saying to Chris,
that stinks.
Don't do it.
It's not right.
You know?
And obviously Jenny knew what he was talking about cause he was one of the best
fucking comics in history.
I talk about them all the time on the show that he was like the one guy.
When people talk about some of the all time greats,
the one God that they leave out,
I'm like,
you didn't see him in the 80s he missed it.
If you saw Jenny in the eighties early nineties he's one of the best of all
time.
How could you not think this guy?
He had to see him though.
The way we saw he,
he would take a premise and bringing it to a whole nother level.
He w he was the guy.
You know like when people say like your jokes,
like you take a premise and you just use squeeze all the juice out of it or
right when you think you can't get any more out of it,
you take it to another place.
I learned that watching Jenny,
I really did because I remember thinking that I was just scratching the surface
of these subjects,
whereas he understood how to explore all of them.
He,
uh,
I'll tell you another one I watch and when I watch dom,
I rera I'm going,
this is one of the funniest guys alive.
No,
he,
he just a powerhouse.
She's a murderer.
Fucking power talking shit.
Like he's the,
one of the best guys ever on killed Tony.
Like when will kill Tony is this podcast that we do.
Um,
and they'll have like new comics,
like open microbes to grow up and do one minute and then it'll be like Dahmer
Breira,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
Brian,
maybe me and the different comics,
you know,
like Russell Peters,
I said all these different comics will sit in on a,
do a guest spot and dom Irrera murders his fucking eyes.
I mean murders them.
He breaks it down.
I mean,
and it's effortless for him.
You're crying and laughing.
I mean,
that's,
if you guys ever do one of doing that as a television show,
you really should have dom on like permanently.
Like,
he's the guy,
he's your best
pages.
Unnecessary as,
as the singer guy.
I think we do that in New York.
Sharad had a show at the comic strip where the new comics would go on like five
of them and then we'd sit there and judge,
but they did like five minutes and you don't want to destroy their dreams,
but you have to be honest with them,
you know,
cause she was just going to have false hope.
And a lot of comics do have false hope because no one will tell them exactly.
No one will call him,
you know,
this is how you do it.
When I first started,
I,
I mean I stunk last year,
but I really stunk when I started.
Uh,
you don't find your voice to,
who knows when,
you know,
you've got to,
it's a lot of things,
a lot of work and there's a lot of being honest and there's a lot of listening
to yourself and there's a lot of correction and everybody doesn't start from the
same spot.
Some guys start out funnier than you and you just got to accept that.
You can't judge yourself by that.
You just
got to keep going.
Just keep going and keep trying to improve on what you do.
Like when you say,
this is what I wanted to ask,
when you would write for Chris,
like how,
what did the process,
what was it like two guys meet in an office?
Like how did,
how did it work for the Oscars,
for any of the things you did?
Well,
the movie,
we'd sit on the set [inaudible] and if you saw him do one thing and it didn't
always have to be funny,
you can go,
uh,
maybe say it that way or walking from here and do it,
take your shirt off or do you know what I mean?
It just had different eyes on him cause he was directing besides ash writing
[inaudible] and writing.
So,
you know,
when he has different,
I,
you know,
he had another comic,
uh,
his name's slipping my mind and another semi,
another director,
uh,
Nelson George and,
and,
and you know,
and it's exact.
And coach was on the set to,
this is all for top five.
Right?
And,
and not every day was I,
you know,
uh,
and it see something,
or you say a line,
you know,
uh,
and he,
and when Chris liked that,
you could tell he liked it and if he didn't,
like you're gone,
you know.
So,
and for the Oscars,
he pretty much had his own stuff.
He kinda knew what he wanted to do for that,
but he would say to the comics,
and he had like 13 writers.
He had,
you know,
chef wrote Apollo,
uh,
lands,
and his crew.
And,
uh,
still sin was the head,
you know,
I guess the head writer Jeff Stilson,
you know me and you know,
he'd go out to the comedy club and he goes,
well,
I'm going to laugh factory now.
Who are,
who wants to come?
Whoever wants to come,
I'll be at,
and some of them didn't go,
but I,
we went,
I went every night to sit and watch and,
and you know,
this is the set he's going to do at the Oscars and then,
you know,
notes and give notes.
But with the Oscars,
we didn't give them to,
I didn't give no write down.
I sent mine in and I think they went through still sin then to him,
you know,
so I,
I mean,
I'm not going to say I got one or two things on,
which was great.
You know,
fucking,
I just wrote for the comedy Central Roast for Bieber and I'm not a right or like
that.
Bonnie's to right.
Bonnie can write you,
you want something fucking written us Bonnie,
she'll fucking write a book.
I mean,
just big how to write.
Uh,
I'm not,
yeah,
he knows how to write.
Right.
So,
but row stuff,
I can come up with some stuff,
you know,
and,
and punching up,
I can,
I'm good at,
because I could see from my,
you know,
just from being a standup for 30 years and watching,
uh,
that there was certain things that Chris goes,
yeah,
that's right.
You know,
and the other comics,
yeah,
he's smart.
Christmas smart.
He has,
he keeps funny people around him to tell him,
you know what I mean?
But that's one of the reasons why he's careers lasted so long.
He said
he's open minded like that,
you know,
cause there's a,
there's a big drop off in a lot of people's acts,
you know,
you'll see like early sets are really,
really good and then you know,
as it gets they get older and older,
they become almost like a caricature of themselves.
Kennison has always,
my best example of that,
I can listen,
I think in 86 is if it wasn't the greatest of all time.
He's like,
it's him and prior.
Yeah.
I feel like from 86 to 88 he was the greatest of all time.
I mean he was on monster and people,
people who are alive today,
you have to look at him and perspective.
You have to look at in perspective of what was around back then there was
nothing like that.
Then he came out of nowhere and he just didn't last.
The,
the stuff that he put out before his death was dog shit.
It was like an open Mike or doing an impression of Kinison and it was terrible.
You know what I did?
I heard one of those albums and I'm going to what?
Uh,
but he was way ahead of his time,
you know,
when it came to such edgy,
teary.
Oh,
he just was doing coke and partying and hanging out and does,
this wasn't a lot of writing going on.
And who also,
I'm sure there's a lot of yes.
Men in his fucking corner all.
Yeah,
because all those guys were like,
when Jenny and Jenny worked with them on a specials too.
Right.
Didn't he work with them on soda?
Who worked with him?
I was always at fascinating,
like how they did that.
If they sat in a room and went over material.
I've seen Chris Prepare,
I've seen him come down.
I was at bananas one night on a weekend,
the one in Jersey,
and I saw him after he goes,
so you're up and down and this this weekend.
I go,
do you want,
if you want to stop stopping.
And you know,
he stopped in on Saturday,
this was two years ago and did 45 minutes,
but he was working out stuff,
you know,
it was all new stuff.
So when stopping him,
is he doing it after your set or some point?
We went on before me.
He went on and the host.
Yeah.
Shopping.
So you wait like an extra 45 minutes for you go.
Yeah,
no big deal.
It's Chris Riley.
Well the we the middle,
we took off the show,
we took the middle off and the host did like,
you know,
maybe in the middle did five minutes,
whatever.
And then Chris came in and did,
you know,
cause he doesn't want to hang out and fall,
wait for me to be get done.
He wants to get in and get out.
So he went on and it was pretty much new stuff and some kills.
I mean,
you know,
you know when you're Chris Rock and your Seinfeld or,
or Lilly,
you have a,
I guess a three minute pass to walk on stage and the audience is like,
oh,
but you have to be funny after,
after you get that right,
her scope,
the fucking show,
just stop.
Just stop.
Just pay attention,
just talk.
So you know what I mean?
There's,
you get a free few minutes pass.
But even with this new stuff,
he would,
he was,
it was almost honed.
So he had it,
you know,
and would see Chris walk up to the seller,
come in when he's working on a new walk in with this notebook,
put it down,
you know,
and just,
and he would still own stuffing to,
you know,
kind of get to calm to keep the crowd going,
and,
but,
but you watch them and,
and,
and it's brilliant.
But the thing I love about love that he loves comedy.
He knows comedy.
Like we'll sit and talk and like,
we'll say Rita Rudner,
he'll go one of the best joke writers ever,
and she is a great coke writer.
Read a runner,
knows how to write a joke,
you know,
and,
and Chris knows fucking comedy.
He could talk.
He said to my wife,
he goes,
look,
if you have a fucking hour,
good material and you're female and you're not famous,
something's fucking wrong.
You know,
you know what I'm saying?
for a female,
a good hour,
you know,
he knows comedy,
he fucking loves comedy.
And that's why I love being with Bonnie.
She loves comedy.
She knows comedy.
She could break down and see,
you know what's good and what's bad and what's hack.
She'll tell me you can't do that.
Do you write like in front of a computer,
on a piece of paper,
just write on stage.
It just got to come to me on stage.
Like I,
I have this,
my,
the best bit I read recently came to me from being on stage and it was,
it's a kid,
it just kills.
It just fucking kills.
So I'm opening my hour.
It,
you don't ever try to like sit down in front of a computer.
Never.
Never in a million.
If I was writing for like tough crowd or unread,
I or you know when I was on one of those round tables,
yeah,
you gotta write fucking dumb jokes.
And even for red,
I'd barely,
I bite align and hopefully I can ad Lib my way through the show because you
know,
it's fucking the day I'm not getting paid.
Anyhow,
so I went to fuck how much,
but with tough crowd you would,
or I'd wrote,
I wrote stuff that Fox News show.
Yeah,
the late at night.
Now it's a round table.
Do you feel my lit at night to not a film at eight eight eight eight eight eight
8:00 PM Oh and it comes on at night.
[inaudible] it's a good show for what it is.
It's,
you know,
Bonnie's guest hosting it tonight.
She's host guest hosts saying she'll be on tonight.
I've never watched it.
I've only seen them.
I've seen a couple of clips of comics on it or people saying controversial
things on it,
but I've never understood what it is.
It's like,
it's it,
it's like any of the other round table show.
It's like Fox News.
Yeah.
I used to do jewelry pay harm when she was on CNN and that was round table,
you know.
Uh,
she's a bright woman.
She's fucking smart by very bright,
but she's so left.
Look when you're so left and so right to me.
Uh,
it,
a lot of it,
you become delusional.
Well,
it gets,
you can't ideological look,
you're locked into a rigid way of thank you.
Got You got to have a bending point.
It can't be all white and black.
It just can't be what it is.
Like her big issues.
Well,
I mean she's just so left.
She hates to write Bush.
Everything he did was completely wrong.
Everything Obama does this completely right.
So she's an Obama supporter even after all these years.
Well they like I've seen,
I haven't done her showing so long,
but she's very left wing and she's now,
no it's gone.
But she was so pro comic and show,
you know,
I mean uh,
her show,
she had comics on all the time.
I did her show 23 times,
you know,
two emails.
Uh,
she sent you two emails?
No,
from fans you got now I always know my,
her fan base was a little older.
They don't get online.
Not,
they don't go there.
Don't fucking write emails.
You,
you get emails from niche from both Democrats that live in the cities.
That what it is.
Yeah.
I got to email me.
You are funny.
But she,
she's pro comic.
She was great.
Our movie,
she did our movie.
Uh,
you know,
so her red eye is basically that type of show to me.
You know,
you know,
people say Bill Maher's show was to first,
but tough crowd was a whole,
it was to first at what
of comics pretty much saying what they wanted to say and saying what you
couldn't say on other shows and not only disagree in which somebody smacking
them around a little for being stupid.
Okay.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
It was a great show.
It was,
why don't they read?
We bring that day.
It just,
it tough crowd to bring it back.
I mean Collin Quinn still alive.
Yeah.
Look,
the fuck is he doing a podcast because it can even be a good podcast.
Tough crowd podcast.
Honig great.
Collin puts out,
Collin puts out one man shows he he's working on his next one.
He did a unconstitutionally did uh,
the one before it.
Does he like doing that better than stand up?
Well,
I guess he's so fucking brilliant,
man.
He just,
I guess stand up is too easy.
Forum or he's not saying anything he wants to say like he's doing in these one
man shows,
you know,
and it stands is confined by the,
the desire to get,
you know,
you have to get laughs every x amount of second and also too.
Yeah.
He could go into theaters and do these shows.
You can't do these shows and comedy clubs really.
Right.
You know,
that's a different kind of structure.
It's a whole different thing.
And you know,
he,
he's,
I just talked to him when I was driving here.
He and I go,
you done with your thing?
He goes,
yeah,
and a book deal.
You know,
he's done with his book,
but the guys always fucking creating,
he's always creating a,
she a happy guy.
I Thi I think he's really centered,
you know,
I think he's really centered because I called them the Bouche something one day
that I was really fucking torn apart about.
Or uh,
he goes,
you did you go to a meeting or whatever.
I say,
he goes,
yeah,
see it's all bullshit.
Go fucking get in touch with what's really bothering you.
And you know what I mean?
So he's pretty centered as a person and I think he's uh,
uh,
I think he's comfortable in his own skin.
You know what I mean?
Like,
so many people are not comfortable,
you know,
and they're hiding and are,
well that's her way.
She's really good at like playing that silly part on Twitter.
Like if you go to Taco to call it Quinn's Twitter,
if you don't understand his sense of humor,
people like words.
The funny I,
you know,
I'm not seeing how you're funny.
Like,
you know,
you don't,
you're missing what he's doing and he doesn't try to convert those people ever.
No,
you don't see them arguing with them.
He doesn't block them like I will.
He's fucking,
he's,
it's so they don't get the fact that he's making fun of everything and he's
playing a character.
I'm there like,
so fucking,
they had a big article in New York Times about him on Twitter.
How,
how,
how good he is on Twitter.
He's like the number one I heard dorm.
I haven't fought her nor Mcdonald's.
Really funny.
He does golf play by play.
Golf.
I haven't really,
I heard a fucking brilliant,
no,
it was just funny.
He figured,
uh,
so he had Collin.
So probably the reason to show never came back.
Well one,
it leaned a little to the right.
You know,
I mean Nick Lean to the right column.
Lean to the right.
I Guess Geraldo was neutral.
He was a little more left.
Yeah,
he was who?
Geraldo.
He was left heroes.
The last little left Norton's a little right was at the time a little trite.
Norns more neutral.
Now I was more to the right then,
but I'm neutral now.
Well I think with Norton laws,
well he was a,
and still is.
I think he's anti the hypocrisy of the left.
That's what I completely,
their heads the hip because it's like all the idea.
If you put it on paper and you had a checklist of what do you actually support?
Gay Marriage check,
you know,
racially quality check,
like all the things that the left pushes for.
I'm in their corner on almost all of it.
But then it gets to certain things that you just go,
well you guys are just silly.
You know,
like there's,
there's certain aspects of,
of the Eni all laughter,
all right.
Ideology.
It's like you can't,
like the worst thing to me is what I'm talking to someone and they talk about
the Democrats.
Like,
look,
we got to win in 2016 like what does this,
we are you are you,
are you running for president?
We got to win I guess as a team for you.
And then you realize what kind of is a team for that.
Yeah.
It becomes this,
you know,
patriots versus the fucking Steelers or something.
It just gets,
it gets to one of those things people voted for Obama.
See a lot of young,
if you're under 25 you're not supposed to,
you,
you shouldn't have a point of view.
Shut your fucking mouth.
You haven't lived long enough to know.
You probably shouldn't be able to vote unless,
unless you could write
a paper explaining why you,
you,
you want Obama or this guy and then you can have it read by people who,
you know,
have the brain,
have life experiences.
But that doesn't make sense either because,
well,
people,
people when he won,
which people wanted something different,
but people voted the first selection out of emotions,
not out of an intellect.
Well,
I thought he was good out of intellect.
I thought he was good.
First of all,
he was so much more articulate than Bush.
He was so much money against Bush,
but it doesn't matter.
It's like coming back from that and it's like,
okay,
now we have someone who actually can talk.
He's obviously brilliant.
Uh,
he's a very smart person.
And his ideas,
like the idea is about closing Guantanamo Bay,
getting into this happened wars.
No,
it didn't,
you know,
but,
but that's what you learn.
You learn from a guy like Obama that it doesn't matter that this,
that the what really,
what politics really all about is about stroking the back of the people that got
you there.
It's a business.
What you gotta do to keep your business running.
Yeah.
Okay.
Farrakhan is a fucking brilliant speaker.
Farrakhan is a Greg,
you ever heard him speak?
He's a great speaker.
He fucking captivates.
He,
he keeps you let you know.
So,
uh,
but what are they saying?
What is any politician saying that hasn't been fucking said before?
Not much.
Okay.
They're saying the same thing in a different uh,
change.
Yeah.
Well,
of course everybody wants to fucking change.
Nobody's fucking happy that uh,
the,
you know,
mortgages are sky high.
Interest rates are fucking less than half a percent.
Nobody wants to let you know at times a gas prices were $4 a gallon.
Yeah,
of course you want change,
but all that other stuff is bullshit.
It's all bullshit.
It's just damn trying to keep their business fucking running.
My business involves having people donate money to them to get them into office.
Yeah.
And then keeping those people happy once they get in office.
I mean,
that's what we found out about Bama.
Bama,
if you look at him on paper,
first of all,
the stuff that he's done against whistle blowers,
that was a whole part of his campaign that if we,
if someone comes forward exposing illegal activity,
we will protect them.
I mean,
that was a part of the,
we are change website.
They,
they redacted that from the website in light of the Edward Snowden,
Chelsea handler shit.
All Chelsea handler,
Chelsea Manning,
uh,
what she take Chelsea shirt again.
No,
that's how strong Chelsea handler is as a personality.
You say the word Chelsea,
you have to say [inaudible] handler after it.
Not even Clinton and Chelsea Clinton.
Um,
you know,
uh,
all that shit that happened with wikileaks,
you know,
it's the idea that they're protecting whistle blowers has been,
it's been debunked.
I mean,
there's none of that.
that was part of the promise that they were saying in an office.
Like if people come forth and expose the illegal activity,
we're going to protect them.
Well,
they did and you didn't.
And that was a core component of what people were looking forward from him,
that he was going to be different than these fucking criminals that were in
charge before he was in there.
Right.
Fucking the FBI,
even your local detective is not going to fucking burned or informants because
there were informants are,
what are you giving them numbers?
Uh,
but the problem is that these guys with Edward Snowden did with Chelsea manning
did,
was expose them and you know,
that's the government,
that's the very people that he works for us.
The idea of whistle blowers wasn't nearly as attractive when they're blowing the
whistle on the actual government themselves.
Leveling whistleblowing on corporations are whistle blowing on,
you know,
the,
the people that fucking spilled the oil out in the middle of the Gulf coast.
It was,
yeah,
it was the actual government itself,
the NSA,
the CIA,
and they were like,
do you think since he's been,
I mean,
since he's been in an office and this is right.
I mean racial divide has grown I think immensely since he's been at all.
Cause I needed some ways,
but in some ways it's actually come around.
I think people are,
are,
are United in a sense and a lot of ways because they realize how much racism
there really is,
how much racism black people have to deal with.
And it comes to the police.
When you watch all these videos of black people being harassed by the cops or
beaten up by the cops or the Eric Gardner guy getting choked to death,
he articulates.
It should never happen,
but it probably wouldn't happen if that was a white guy in a suit.
And we all know that.
Yep.
But we know of.
Okay.
But you know,
as much as the media exploits every now,
every fucking time you see now there's a cop doing something wrong or doing this
wrong or you're not seeing,
uh,
you know,
for fucking criminals walking down the street,
you don't know if they're fucking pack in a weapon.
You don't see them harass.
It's all right now with selling fucking papers and we're saying papers loosely
is what are the cops doing to black people?
That's what's selling right now.
That's what's headlines are.
And it may look as many bad cops and,
and you know,
it's maybe one out of 21 out.
Uh,
you know,
the percentages,
dis,
you know,
like this display,
the,
I didn't see the documentary made a documentary about Aa.
All the predators in Aa,
all the uh,
you know,
the criminals and this and that and people take an advantage.
Well you guess what?
You got fucking people,
people in,
you know,
you got peoples in rooms that were fucking ex ex heroin addicts in and out of
jail.
Some killers suddenness yeah,
there's gonna be some,
well,
you're dealing with millions and millions of people here.
Look at it this way.
How many people do you think get arrested by the cops or have interaction with
the cops every fucking day of the week?
Across the entire country.
It's got to be in the hundreds of thousands of interactions every day.
So these glaring instances,
like the guy in South Carolina that's shot,
that guy fucked up,
unbelievably fucked up.
What happened in Baltimore?
Fucked,
fucked up.
What happened in Ferguson?
Fucked up those fucked up instances.
Those become like something that they can focus on because those are,
those are these,
these blips and they're in the overall scheme of things in comparison to how
many interactions people actually have with the cops.
The,
the amount of times people get shot in those situations are fairly small,
but we're dealing with hundreds of millions of people and the interactions of
hundreds of millions of people on a daily basis and you're going to find things
to focus on.
Does it mean there's no problem now?
It's definitely a fucking problem if those,
if one of those things happen,
that's a problem that that one instance is a problem getting a Staten Island was
unwatched.
Which ones is to have the choke?
The,
she was recording.
I'm fucking Wanky,
but do you think the cops went in there with the mindset,
I want to kill this guy?
Well,
they fucked up because they make,
they were getting,
well,
first of all,
they used cops to collect revenue.
That's a problem.
That's part of the problem and he's like,
they use cops to write tickets.
They use cops too to make arrest.
They have quotas that's fucked up.
They're doing that because they want to make money and they want these cops to
be profitable for them.
If no one did any crime,
what the fuck would cops do if they have quotas?
If there was no crime,
if the whole country agreed to have a moratorium on crime for like three weeks,
what the fuck would everybody do?
They would have to start planning crime.
They'd have to start freaking crime and arresting people for Shit.
That didn't happen.
But that's the same as saying if there was no fires,
firemen wouldn't know.
It's not because there's oftentimes no fires for years and no one ever talks
about like,
hey,
we don't need the fire department anymore anymore.
Everybody knows that fires are always possible,
so you want to keep a fire department.
If anybody ever ran for mayor said,
it's saying,
look,
we don't need a fire department.
Everybody just stopped playing with matches.
All right,
we're good.
We just cut money off the budget.
They would go,
Whoa,
what?
What the fuck are you talking about?
But the idea of having no cops because uh,
there was no crime would welcome that.
They would welcome that.
Like,
oh,
we don't need carbs.
There's no crime anymore.
Like you,
you can't,
you can't like force these people to make arrests.
And the idea of putting quotas on cops.
If you have lazy cops that don't go out and enforce the law,
well then you need to get better cops.
But what you can't do is you can't make people arrest people because if you make
people recipe,
well you're assuming someone's going to do something bad if no one did anything
bad.
Isn't that the whole point of having a police presence?
Like the whole point of having a police presence is people realize,
oh there's cops.
I don't want to do anything like that.
But if that happened,
those costs would be fuck.
Cause they have quotas,
you know,
and people tried to say there's no quotas.
Both course your shoulders traps and shit.
I know cops,
they tell me,
even if there's unwritten quotas,
there's quotas.
This pressure on them to arrest people.
And it's been proven time and time again does quotas.
And it's,
it varies by department.
It varies by city and state.
But without a doubt,
there's a lot of pressure on people to arrest people so they can get funding.
Yes,
yes,
of course.
I mean did they make money?
And these fucking,
these forfeiture asset forfeiture situations where people are getting their,
their money taken from him.
This fucking kid,
there was one on Amtrak.
The Dea is a catching people on Amtrak that cause some kid had money saved up.
He had $16,000 on him.
Clean,
clear criminal record,
no fucking history of drug sales,
no history of drug use.
He took his fucking money,
got to go to Amtrak.
Civil forfeiture.
The DEA is involved.
The civil forfeiture cases,
it's talking disgusting man.
Well here's one of them.
Rich land want four point $1 million police station funded by civil forfeiture.
You fucking criminals,
criminals.
You're stealing money from the people that you're supposed to be fucking
protecting.
They steal and then you have to take them to court and you have to try to get
that money back.
Even if somebody made money from selling drugs,
even if they made money from selling drugs,
that's not the fucking police department's money.
They can't take that money.
And by Margarita machines and all this shit they've been accused of doing,
cause that's what they have been.
They've been convicted of doing that.
It's awful.
Elisha,
a whole corrupt society.
I mean,
well,
it's corrupt because they've been allowed to be corrupt cause they've got
incompetent shitheads that are running these police departments and good cops or
forced into bad situations.
If you have it on the books that they're allowed to take money from people,
then it's up to their discretion and then you have these fucking idiots that you
know,
just decide to pull the trigger and you're going to have a certain amount of
idiots in any group of people.
If you have 500 people,
you've got five idiots.
No matter what you do,
no matter what you do,
you pull any 500 people,
five of them,
you're going to want to kill the fucking hammer.
They're assholes.
No matter what you do.
There's a certain amount of people,
they're just dumb as shit.
There's four initial,
meanwhile,
I know one of these and Nydia right hear me,
but I know occasionally sound like one.
Here's I.
You can't get it.
Like,
look,
if they want to put,
if they want to take your property and build a highway through your fucking
property,
they'll do it.
They're not going to do it.
They're not doing it anymore.
They're not doing it anymore because of stories like that,
because people find out about asset forfeiture,
they're just,
they're started to rescind those laws.
They're starting to pull those laws back.
They shouldn't just pull those ball,
but you're not get,
they should,
they should put everyone who fucking was a part of that in jail,
everyone will let people take some kids $16,000 and you make them go to court
for it and how much money costs to fight against and then the the do you have to
pull receipts for how you made that $16,000 this is supposed to be America.
Okay.
You're supposed to be innocent until proven guilty.
You find what's $16,000 isn't that much fucking money.
It's not like the guy had $2 billion in gold bullion.
Like where'd you get it?
Fuck you.
Okay.
You lose a settled down,
but you,
you might've done something illegal to get $2 billion.
You only 12 no,
this is a kid who earned money and they stole it from them because they decided
it was reasonably suspicious.
But you're going,
you're going for,
you're going from a whole different,
from the police officer on the street doing what they gotta do to,
to stop crime and keep stay alive to the bureaucrats that are passionate.
He's fucking laws and d they're just pawns to cops are just plunge into chess.
He may start out as pawns,
but somewhere along the line,
a lot of times they wind up being fucking legal criminals then wind up doing
illegal,
which should be illegal.
Shit.
Does legal have to club owners?
We were four shoulders fucking show shows you have to.
Corporations had one just got caught dumping,
you know,
they're all fucking,
bend a bank started biggest less than half a percent interest.
But when you're alone,
you take out a loan,
you're paying what,
four or 5% interest,
6% on a loan,
you know.
So you agree to do that.
I mean,
that's something you say,
well okay,
I'll agree to that.
You have no choice.
The choices to not get that loan industry that in someone's stealing your money
when they pull you over cause they decided and you shouldn't have $10,000 on
you.
You know like they've been doing that for a long time.
They've been pulling people over for a long time just taking their money because
if you have money on you,
you have to prove that you got that money through legal means.
That is bullshit and you know it's,
it's situations like that that engender or create this lack of trust in law
enforcement that you created an enemy.
You create an enemy in that kid.
That kid is going to distrust the DEA and the FBI and the CIA.
Anybody pulls him over,
he's going to distrust them forever because you ruined his life for a long
period of time.
The time he's got to go to court,
the sleepless nights he spent thinking of this smirking con that stole his
fucking money with a badge on that criminal with a fucking badge on.
But you know what?
Look I'm and even take money from me where it's talking about black people.
You can't even imagine a struggle because you're not black people,
white liberals,
all I know you're saying you don't know.
You don't know the struggles.
You don't leave the house every day in fear.
Okay.
And stop and Frisk.
Shit.
They were doing any work.
That's Dutch all being exploited because also,
and I agree,
I grew up in a black thing.
I seen it.
I don't,
I never felt it or lived it,
but I seen it.
Okay.
Cause it's actually why I grew up.
So I don't,
I don't,
I had the feeling of antisemitism that I,
that I could feel because that's
what I see and feel.
But you will never see the story of the cops that went in and stopped a gang war
or,
or broke up,
uh,
broke up,
you know,
uh,
a husband from killing his fucking wife on a domestic call that saved his wife
and that family's lives and risk their lives and save two kids cause to fucking
father or even a mother.
Fucking lost to some Zoe,
some bureaucrats,
some dummy,
some administrator,
wherever the fuck.
Yeah.
Pass those regulations that allowed cops to steal money from people.
They're the problem.
You gave them legal power,
you gave him a green light and you made it where it's not even against the law.
And so they feel like they're justified in doing that.
You gotta be very careful of the power that you give people cause it's very
difficult to take that power back.
And it's also very difficult to take that righteous attitude like,
hey,
they have this attitude like what they're doing is just because it's legal
because they can't look at it objectively.
It's hard,
but don't you think
in the morning five cops,
you take five cops
roll call,
they listen.
Don't you think?
I don't know what percentage,
but I would,
let's even say seven out of 10 are not going five and then there's seven out of
10 [inaudible] per se.
Say whatever the percentage is that most of those cops aren't going to work on.
I'm going to find somebody and take money.
I would.
I would bet that most shows cops are gone.
I'm going to try to do something good today.
I'm going to try to,
I'm sure a lot of them.
Okay.
Um,
I'm sure it more are there to protect and serve then there are to fuck you over.
I,
and I'm pretty,
you know,
you know what I mean?
So the ones that are,
they're risking their lives because they are going to a job where they might not
come home.
They might not fucking come home.
Like I said it.
Well,
it's not them.
It's the fucking pattern.
I sent them the laws that passed laws that allow them to do these things.
Okay?
But the Lord is legal,
but Deloitte you're talking about is where they can take that money.
Jesus,
one of them.
Okay.
But he'll stop and frisk.
Imagine if you're a black guy and you walk into New York and you've done nothing
wrong.
You're going to school and some asshole with a fucking,
you know,
a chip on his shoulder thinks it's okay for him to touch your body.
So rifling through your fucking pockets for no reason.
How may maybe calls you a racial slur in the process.
If you resist him and there's nothing,
not a goddamn thing you can do about it.
But do you don't think that happens in,
in white as a matter if it happens in white areas?
I'm just saying like that happening at all because you gave them the
possibility,
you let them on paper,
you made it legal for them to do that as soon as you make it legal for them to
do things that are inappropriate,
that don't make any sense.
Like if there's no,
there's no real reasonable like reason to,
to search something that are not in the middle of something criminal.
They're not doing anything suspicious.
They're just walking on the street.
That's discrimination and you're,
you're giving them a legal precedent.
You giving them a legal on paper reason to pull someone over and be a cunt.
Okay.
And you're right.
But how many,
how many uh,
Sherril killers,
how many rapists,
how many kidnappers have been caught due to profiling the FBI?
I mean that's not putting whole file is not,
yes it is profiling because they're looking at people like people all over for
stop and Frisk was and how do you know in Ohio that debt,
you're just lives in New York City law that stop and Frisk.
She's only in New York.
It was always,
that was where it was widely criticized and I'm sure cops do similar things in
other places,
but they stop you.
They,
if you're going through the fucking a Toledo,
Ohio and you see four white kids that look like trouble fit a profile,
cops will fuck with them.
Although asking me questions,
but they're not legally allowed to start searching through their pockets like
they were in New York,
what they were doing in New York that stop and Frisk Shit is bullshit.
It's fucked.
Okay.
I don't know enough about it.
I don't know the crime statistics.
I do do believe in certain types of profiling,
but we wouldn't catch him.
You know,
all the terrorism that has been stopped in this country,
which we don't even know about and they're spending a lot.
Okay.
Since nine 11 day have caught a lot of fucking people.
They've also been trapped a lot of people and forced him to do and terrorist
like that guy in Dallas,
they took some way.
I was like mentally challenged.
They forced him into this situation where they,
they gave him a fake bomb and gave him like a cellular phone to detonate it.
And then as soon as he tried to detonate it,
they arrested him like,
yeah,
yeah.
It's a famous case.
The fucking,
they tricked this dummy and they,
they,
they talked to me,
he got it.
Probably would have never found the means or the resources to have this bomb in
the first place.
Now he's in jail for the rest of his life.
But wait,
was he,
he was willing to make that call and blow that Obama.
Okay,
well guess what,
they,
you can convince people to join Scientology.
You can convince people once they joined Scientology,
should you arrest them for being retarded?
Okay,
here's,
you know,
he's,
I don't think it would,
I don't know the story,
but if a cop can convince some show can have fucking show Ken.
So true,
but shows a lot of idiots out there.
And guess what profiling is,
helps stopping those fucking idiots from,
from committing these fucking shows.
Just attack.
You can make that argument.
You could also make the argument that they're,
what they're doing is they're taking advantage of someone who's stupid and
they're,
they're being like very persuasive and they're getting some dummy to do
something you probably would have never done in the first place and may have
never even made contact with those kind of people in the first place.
Or people that have the resources to do those things.
And when,
and why would they pick somebody like that and let's do it was because we want
to make arrests that that's,
that's real.
It's a score keeping thing.
I mean they want to make
arrests that a lot of them,
yes,
a lot of them are trying to prevent crime and trying to do good.
The vast majority.
But the problem is there's a,
there's enough wiggle room there for assholes and assholes get involved in
police force in law enforcement,
and they fuck it up for everybody else because all the good cops,
they have to think about that guy in South Carolina.
They shot that guy in the back of his running away.
He'll exactly that.
That becomes a bit,
how come you don't hear about the good cops?
No,
not even that.
How come you don't hear that?
What does this in 2012 New Yorkers are stopped by the police.
532,911 times in one year.
473,644 we'll totally innocent.
89% that's criminal.
Okay.
Guess what?
55% were black.
32% that and yeah.
10% know when the whitening,
no teeth.
You know what happens?
Yeah.
Added is looking multiple.
It happen.
No,
it makes me happy about this.
No Jews,
no Jews.
Jews are white paper.
They have Jews in the white category now they put it now it would be June.
Where do you fall into it?
To you?
I'd say maybe,
maybe Latin.
If you start talking Spanish,
if I ran into as a see puppy,
when someone,
people trash white people,
I don't give a fuck if Detroit Jewish,
I get upset.
But white people or Jews,
Jews are white people but not with no wasp or white people.
And it was right after,
you know it's,
it's weird cause you look at 2012 how big it is.
And then look how in 2014 the big drop.
What was it that stopped it?
They got it.
They got in trouble.
It was 2000 they sued the fuck.
Wait a second.
Whoa,
whoa.
A lot of lawful.
Cause he'd say,
look at 8% in 2011 the kiss,
what gets you up?
You're not saying you stole.
Almost all of it is 80 plus percent innocent.
But guess what?
In these statistics and these statistics,
they're not saying whether a crime has risen or dropped since.
Fuck.
You can't just,
you can't just ruin people's lives.
You can't just arrest people,
Frisk him,
fuck with them,
give them all this crazy stress.
If they're totally innocent in 2006 it was 90% innocent.
It's ridiculous.
It's a stupid policy.
This start right after nine 11 no.
Well it started after nine 11 but they're deep into 2012 and they were doing it
when it first started.
Yeah,
2000 to 86% were totally us.
I always may you actually time when this started in 2012 who was mayor?
Was it Giuliani?
Well,
he was,
yeah,
he was the head.
He was the head district attorney.
This guy was,
he was a sucker.
Nine out of 10 stop and Frisk in New York.
Has it been completely innocent?
That's not good.
And it makes you wonder like,
like what is that one?
Oh,
he had some weed on them or you know,
they had like an ax.
It's all okay.
Yeah,
injustice.
There's fucking injustice throughout this world.
There's injustice amongst blacks.
White Jews brought women,
but obviously way more blacks than whites.
And if you know the numbers,
there's way more white people than black people in New York.
There's 13 profiling.
There's countries.
That's an illegal policy.
I mean that,
that if you might be legal,
but it's an immoral,
unjust,
unethical,
racist policy.
Should there be racial profile and towards Middle Easterns?
No.
You don't think so?
No at all.
No.
Racial profiling.
You look,
if you know something about someone's past,
too many fucking people are in the Middle East.
The only people that are in the Middle East that aren't terrorists,
the vast majority.
So you're saying like because a small percentage are terrorists,
you should racially profile the vast majority of innocent people and subject
them to all sorts of scrutiny.
White people at the airport.
Why?
Why is it the airport when I know is going to pick fucking ass car racing?
I shit.
You know,
it seems like there's a lot more people to be killed that larger areas and it's
something about airplanes.
They're terrifying already.
So terror and airplanes just ramps it up even further.
We have the smartest people in the world that are supposedly running these
countries.
These airlines.
Do you know history,
how different issue would be with a fucking,
if Joe is a $5 dead bolt on that fucking cockpit door.
Okay.
To show deadbolt.
How after all the hijackings to Cuba,
how much would that Guy Marshall's on planes?
If there was sky Marshall's on planes before nine 11 nine 11 would've never
happened.
Don't they would've just taken those fucking guys out.
Pack Doc tech note a bit of rap.
That'd been the end of it.
You have highly trained cops,
you know a mercenaries.
You'd get some black water guys where the fuck you gotta do guys who've been to
war?
No how to kill people and you put them on these planes to guard them from
assholes with box cutters and you're done.
I mean you just,
you,
you cost a little money.
And the idea that there were unprotected from something like that and the idea
that you could use a plane as a weapon and that had been considered long before
September 11th I mean they had talked about that many,
many times.
But what would happen if terrorists took,
hold me.
That was,
that was not a like a like an unthought of scenario.
So how,
give me,
none of these fucking CEO's are hedging these airlines said we fucking locked
pilots in.
We save money.
They don't open the door under any circle.
How about that flat land guy in Germany,
the pilot went to take a shit.
The copilot who's depressed decides to fly the plane into a,
into a mountain,
a mountain.
They can't even get inside.
I mean,
that's insane.
They're pounding on the door and this,
this asshole just drops the plane right down into a mountain.
I mean,
how the fuck is that possible?
How is there no fail safe method to get inside that plant?
Or how was,
how do they not have a phone where they going to override where they can call
someone and who could override the controls?
It seems to me like there should be another way into that car and I wonder how
hard it is to break that fucking door down.
Yeah,
I mean I,
which it's probably like a vault.
It's probably one of those big heavy metal doors and it seems pretty big.
But I wonder,
I wonder how hard it is.
I wonder how hard it is to break down.
I wonder what's happening physically pass whole pilot just fluid into your
mouth.
Yeah,
it was totally,
totally intentional.
He was depressed.
He was on anti depressants who suicidal.
He was,
he was all,
it was,
he was all fucked up.
I mean,
suicide is selfish.
Should be good.
I mean,
I can't deal with it.
I don't know.
I don't know anybody.
But to take a whole fucking plane cut off the bat.
Bucking emotions motherfucking.
Yeah.
And again,
you know,
we've focused on that.
Meanwhile this,
how many thousands of planes fly successfully every day and we don't even think
about not one parachute on the plane though.
Well,
you would die anyway,
man.
30 30,000 feet.
You wouldn't have any air when you jumped out.
You probably would die of having no air.
And on top of that,
it'd be freezing.
Fucking cold.
The,
the,
the idea that you would be fine and you would make it like when you parachute,
you don't really parachute from that high.
It's very prayers moving.
When they dance they do.
They have like all sorts of special equipment,
oxygen tanks and shit.
Here's uh,
uh,
it was on,
I don't know,
60 minutes or something and I didn't see it.
Bonnie told me,
and it makes sense,
if you went on a plane wearing a helmet or brought a helmet on,
your chances of survival are a lot better because most people when a plane
crashes,
hit,
hit their head on the fucking seat or whatever.
They get knocked out unconscious and they burned to death.
So if you got to fucking helmet,
boom,
you hit your head to credit,
probably going out.
Anyway,
I got news for you.
I mean you could helmet going 500 miles an hour.
You're,
your fucking head is Jello.
Even that side of the hill,
when they catch guys who die in motorcycle accidents,
they called them squids because there they have helmets on,
but their neck gets snapped anyway.
And so they're like a squid.
The everything below the hard stuff is just mush or how come I'm waiting for the
airplane?
Oh man,
that really fucking defeated my fucking theory.
Cause every time I go on to play now,
I tried to get a blanket in case you're just going to crash.
I like a turban.
We gotta wrap this up.
I gotta get Outta here unfortunately.
How can they really don't make God damned when I'm a hunter?
Just float.
How come on.
I don't know.
I bring it to another level.
I don't know if Tom and Christine does what Bonnie and I do.
Find out the rose,
the rose.
Rose Rose bad.
Will you guys be willing to fly in for this?
Yeah,
probably.
We want to,
you want to do a week of vacation in here anyhow.
Okay.
Well tell me when you're doing it.
I'll have you guys both in studio together and uh,
we'll,
we'll promote it.
Yeah,
but we got to do in a club,
you mean,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I'm saying you and Bonnie have you guys in studio to promote it and maybe I'll
have Tom and Christina and studios on a different day or maybe in the same fun
chaos.
Yeah,
it sounds fucking total chaos.
Yeah.
We'll do it.
Or we got to end this weekend.
Best Ventura County Club.
Thank you for having me.
Fucking if go see him this weekend,
I guarantee you're going to have a good time.
If you don't have a good time,
you're a shithead and you have a terrible sense of humor.
Rich Vos would be at the venter a comedy club Friday,
Saturday,
and Sunday.
Ventura Harbor Comedy Club.
Google it.
You can find it.
Rich Vos on Twitter.
I love you,
buddy.
Thanks for,
I have it.
All right.